where the darkest places you've ever
gone in your life
the following is a conversation with
carl deisseroth professor of
bioengineering psychiatry and behavioral
sciences at stanford university he's one
of the greatest living psychiatrists and
neuroscientists in the world
he's also just a fascinating human being
we discuss both the darkest and the most
beautiful places that the human mind can
take us
he explores this in his book called
projections a story of human emotions
i highly recommend it it's written
masterfully
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's carl that's roth
you open your book called projections a
story of human emotions with a few
beautiful words that summarize all of
humanity
the book draws insights about the human
mind for modern psychiatry and
neuroscience so if it's okay let me read
a few sentences from the opening
you got to give props to beautiful
writing when i see it
quote
in the art of weaving
warp threads are structural and strong
and anchored at the origin
creating a frame for crossing fibers as
the fabric is woven
projecting across the advancing edge
into free space warp threads bridge
deformed past to the ragged present to
the yet featureless future
yet featureless future well done well
done sir
the tapestry of the human story has its
own warp threads rooted deep in the
gorges of east africa connecting the
shifting textures of human life over
millions of years
spanning pictographs backdrop by
creviced ice
by angulated forestry by stone and steel
and by glowing rare earths
the inner workings of the mind give form
to these threads creating a framework
within us
upon which the story of each individual
can come into being
personal grain and color arise from the
cross threads of our moments and
experiences
the fine weft of life
embedding and obscuring the underlying
scaffold with intricate and sometimes
lovely detail
here are stories of this fabric fraying
in those who are ill
in the minds of people for whom the warp
is exposed and raw
and revealing
what have you learned about human beings
human nature and the human mind from
those who suffer from psychiatric
maladies
for those for whom this fabric is warped
and one thing we learn as biologists is
that when something breaks
you see
what the original
unbroken
part was for and we see this in genetics
we see this in biochemistry
it's known that when you have a mutated
gene
sometimes the gene is turned up in
strength they're turned down in strength
and that lets you see what it was
originally for you can infer
true function from dysfunction
and this is a theme that i thought
needed to be shared
and needed to be
made communicable to the to the lay
public to everybody people who
which is i think uh almost all of us who
think and care about the inner workings
of our minds but who also
care for those who have been suffering
who have
mental health disorders who face
challenges
but then more broadly
it's a very much larger story than the
present there's a
a story to be told where the protagonist
really is the human mind and that was
one thing i wanted to share as well in
projections is that broader story but
still anchored in the moment of
patience of people of
experiences of the moment
is there a clear line between
dysfunction and function disorder and
order
this is always debated in psychiatry
probably more so than any other you know
medical specialty
i'm a psychiatrist i'm i treat patients
still
i see
acutely ill
people who come to the emergency room
where there's no doubt that this is not
something that's working well where the
manifestation of disease is so powerful
where the person is suffering so greatly
where they cannot
continue as they are
but of course it's a spectrum and there
are people who are closer to the to the
realm of being able to work okay in
their jobs but suffer from some small
dysfunction and everywhere in between
in psychiatry we're careful to say we
don't call it a disease or a disorder
unless there's a disruption in social or
occupational functioning
but of course psychiatry has a long way
to go in terms of developing
quantitative tests we don't have
blood draws we don't have imaging
studies that we can use to diagnose
and so that line ultimately
that you're asking about between order
and disorder function and dysfunction
it's operational of the moment how are
things working
can we just like linger on the terms for
a second so this uh disease
uh dysfunction
how careful should we be using those
words can we just even in this
conversation
um from a
sort of technical perspective but also a
human perspective
how um
quick
should we be
in saying that schizophrenia
uh depression
autism
as we kind of go down this uh
across the spectrum of different
maladies like
just to use the word dysfunction and
disease
i would say to give ourselves license to
capture the whole spectrum let's say
disorder because that that captures
truly i think the essence of it which is
we need to talk about it when it's not
working when there's disorder and that
that's the fairest and
you know most uh inclusive term to use
so is it fair to assume that basically
every
member of the human species suffers from
a large number of disorders then
well and we just have to pick which ones
are are debilitating and for each person
you know if you if you look at the
numbers
there are
uh
you know if you look at how our mental
health disorders are currently defined
you can uh look at population prevalence
values for all these disorders and you
can
come up with estimates that
somebody
will have a lifetime prevalence of
having a psychiatric disorder that
approaches 25 or so and so that's
and in some studies it could be more
some studies it could be less now what
do we do with that number what does that
mean and in some ways that's the essence
of what i was hoping to approach with
uh the book is to reflect on this
spectrum that exists for all the
disorders there is
and taking nothing away from the
severity and the suffering that comes at
the extreme end of these illnesses but
nearly every one of them exists on a
spectrum of severity from
nearly functional to completely
dysfunctional life-threatening and and
even fatal
and so that that that number 25 more or
less it doesn't capture
uh that that spectrum of
of uh severity to regard that number
where do those numbers come from is it
self-report is it people who
show up and say i need help is it
somebody else that points out that
person needs help
or is it like estimates that even go
beyond that for people who don't ask for
help or suffering quietly
alone when you look at self-report
numbers that then those numbers get even
higher beyond 25 percent or more
those the most rigorous studies are
done with structured psychiatric
interviews where people
who are trained in eliciting symptoms
carefully do complete psychiatric
inventories of of individuals and these
are
time-consuming laborious studies that
not often repeated when they're done
they're they're done well
but
very often you'll see a report or
something in the news of a very high
number
for some disorder or or symptom and very
often
if it's shockingly high that's coming
from a self-report of a person
and so that's another another issue that
we have again take nothing away from the
severity and reality and and biological
nature of these disorders which are very
genetic very you know we we understand
that these are very biological
and yet
we lack right now the lab tests and the
blood draws to make the diagnoses we'll
talk about it just how biological they
are because it's a that too is a mystery
i mean
you know in terms of from a perspective
of how to probe into the disease how to
understand it and how to help it so some
of it could be neurobiological
some of it could be
uh just the the dance of human emotion
and interaction and the
it's like uh
well it is love when it works and is
love when it breaks down uh biological
or is it something else so we're gonna
talk about it but let me just like to
linger in terms of disorder
what about genius
you know that sort of uh cliche saying
like the
madness and genius that they kind of
danced together uh
what about if the thing we see is this
order is actually
genius unheard or misunderstood
well here again the numbers help us and
here's where being rigorous and
quantitative actually really helps if
you look at disorders like autism
and bipolar disorder
and eating disorders anorexia nervosa
for example
these uh you know particularly bipolar
and anorexia these can be fatal
they can cause immense suffering
but they are heavily genetic all three
of these
and
what's very interesting is each one of
these three is actually correlated
positively
positively with measures of intelligence
of educational attainment
and even of income and so you look at
this severe disorders in many cases
causing
quite immense morbidity and mortality
and yet
they are positively correlated at the
population level with positive things
can you say the the three again autism
autism
anorexia and bipolar disorder bipolar
right what's that book forgot the book
name but uh is intelligence a burden
uh
well you know people can get into
trouble when they think they're smarter
than they are i will say that
i don't know
sometimes like
in the deepest
meaning of that statement i think
ignorance is bliss i'm a big fan of
prince michigan from the idiot and um
i learned from brother karmazov
optimism can be seen as naivete and
dumbness but i think it's a
it's a kind of deep intelligence
maybe inability to reason
uh sort of about the mechanics of the
world but instead kind of feel the world
and it seems like that's a one of the
paths to happiness
there is how much you think versus how
much you feel this comes up all the time
in medicine
we encounter this all the time when you
day after day you encounter this you
know the the abyss of suffering from
patients how much do you let yourself
feel
or how much do you
make it abstract and
and objective and try to make it
clinical
and that range how you're able to move
yourself on that on that spectrum
is very important for survival as a
physician
and the way you
you protect yourself and your feelings
turns out to be very important
so you quote finnegan's wake uh mad
props for that james joy's book i took a
class on james joyce in college
i think i read parts of finning and way
i might have been on drugs of some kind
or
i um i somehow got an a in that class
which probably refers to some kind of
curve where nobody understood anything
the only thing i understood and really
enjoyed is the short stories the dead
and then ulysses i kind of uh i think
read a few cliff notes that kind of got
to the point and then finnegan's wake
was just a hopeless person i it's a you
for people who haven't looked at it
maybe you can
elucidate to me better but
i felt like i was reading things
words and the words made sense
like standing next to each other
but when you
kind of read for a while you realize you
didn't actually understand anything that
was said right but did you have a
feeling though that's one that's one
thing i found interesting about
finnegan's week i i never fully
understood it but the words caused
feelings in me which i found fascinating
and and sometimes i i couldn't predict
it from the the semantic you know black
and white context of what i was seeing
in front of me on the page but the
rhythm or the melody would make me feel
certain ways and that's that was what i
always was intrigued by with joyce of
course that was his
he he existed on a spectrum too and he
wrote as you say you know more
accessible uh works you know i learned a
lot about irish history from you know
portrait of the artist as a young man
and there was just
he could be as objective as he wanted to
be but then when he let himself loose
he was in this realm where the words had
their own
purpose separate from from
you know semantic meaning from their
their dry uh you know dictionary
definition you know there's a funny
story that was told it doesn't matter if
it's true or not but they they said that
uh james joyce when he was young when he
was in his teen years would go around
instead of ireland drinking and so on
and telling everybody that he's going to
be one of if not the greatest writers of
the 20th century
and uh he turned out to be
that
so the that i always think about that
little story that somebody told me
because i have a lot of people come up
to me including myself i'm a bit of a
dreamer
i and
you know you get into certain moods
where you say i'm going to be the
greatest
anything ever you you get like people
tell you this uh young especially young
people
and it kind of
it makes me feel all kinds of ways but
that story reminds me that
like you just might be
one of the greatest
writers of the 21st century for example
if somebody were to tell me that and
like don't
just don't immediately disregard that
because one of the people that say that
that's almost like a pre-condition
that's like a requirement just to
believe in yourself maybe it's not a
full requirement but it's it's an
interesting story
i think when someone tells you that then
it creates uh
one sees an opportunity and then it
would be a tragedy if the opportunity
weren't captured right and so then that
creates a um some some impetus uh some
motivation to do something
something good i think the mind it's
like uh
you know i guess that's what like books
like the books or whatever i don't even
know if it's a book the secret plugs
into uh they kind of make a whole
industry out of it but there is
something about
the mind believing something making it a
reality it is just time and time again
with steve jobs like
your belief in yourself your belief in
an idea
sort of embracing the me versus the
world
embracing the madness of this idea and
making it a life pursuit
somehow morse reality around for some
tiny fraction of the population for
everybody else you descend into uh
you know all the beautiful ways that
failure
materializes in our lifetime
you know you mentioned love earlier i
mean that's that's a great example of
how belief in something makes it real
right it's it's not reasonable
on the face of it but because you
believe it's reasonable then it actually
does become reasonable and then it is
real and so that's a that's a good
example that doesn't happen i'm also in
a bioengineering department we don't
imagine that a bridge is soundly built
and then it is soundly built that's
something that it doesn't come up in too
many realms of human existence but love
is one of them and and these the ability
to
to have a fixed idea and to say it's
true and then it is true
a bridge is a kind of manifestation of
love so maybe it does work a little bit
but you know they can break down like
chernobyl did you can't just say it's
safe you have to also prove it safe
uh but on finnegan's wake
i think maybe correct me if i'm wrong
you're using kind of finnegan's wake to
give one perspective on what madness is
of what's going on in the mind how much
of that is
uh that we're simply unable
to communicate with the person on the
other side
of of their mind like there's almost
like a
a little person inside the brain and
they have some circuitry that's used to
communicate emotion communicate ideas to
the outside world and there's something
about that circuitry that makes it
difficult to communicate with a little
person on the other side so if you look
at what shows up in schizophrenia with
many cases the
what we call thought disorders what we
call
uh the
the individual speech symptoms of
schizophrenia
finnegan's wake is is loaded with them
and it's it's just full of them we we
talk about uh
clang associations in schizophrenia
where the word that is said is
echoes in some way the previous word and
it's we call that a clang association
because there's no other reason than the
similarity of the sound like a like a
clang of a
of a garage door being hit and it has a
and sometimes it's not even a word and
we call that a neologism a new word
being created and of course finnegan's
wake is is full of that and then
uh we we also in schizophrenia where
there's what we call loose associations
or tangential thought processes of
course full of that where things just go
off in directions that are not linear or
logical
and
you can't read finnegan's wake i think
without um
certainly a psychiatrist you can't read
it without thinking about schizophrenia
and then when we look at
the families of people with
schizophrenia and joyce was no exception
there very often are people within the
family who are on the spectrum some have
it
some are
able to see it from a distance from a
safe distance
there's an association between
schizophrenia and what we call
schizotypal personality disorder where
people are not quite in this
severe state of schizophrenia but have
some magical thinking have some unusual
thought patterns very often those are
family members of people with
schizophrenia so this points to this
again to this idea that that there is a
range even along
this very severe
very genetic biological illness that
human beings dwell on different spots
along that spectrum i should mention
that we have my friend sergey pulling up
stuff young sergei or old sergey i don't
know what to call you but
uh there's drafts of finn can squake
yeah i actually saw pictures of this
from um
i think it was on instagram or something
these are early giraffes of finnigan's
wave and it's so beautiful to see for
people who are just listening there's
just random paragraphs and writing all
over the page with stuff crossed out and
it's great to see that joyce himself was
thinking in this kind of way as
um as you're putting it together how
much do you think he was thinking about
schizophrenia this schizophrenic mind i
think a lot i think you know it's it's
known that his daughter suffered from
from schizophrenia and uh
the this is what's depicted here on the
page is something that i'm sure
he either felt himself and some some
level was able to access this
non-linearity of of processing or had
seen enough in family
that he he knew what it was and was able
to to reflect it down in black and white
on the paper so it was what he was able
to do is was quite authentic in that
sense
of course i don't want to
pigeonhole him he was doing much more
than that it was much more than than
talking about altered human
thought processes and thought disorders
but that was an aspect that he was
so good at representing that it had to
be
intentional to some extent and a tiny
tangent what does your own
writing look like for this book because
it's extremely well written
how many edits
did you just drink some whiskey and uh
like i'm imagining hemingway style
what's a very different the the writing
is very different i mean it's really
really well written which was like
i
was reading it
it makes you realize because i was
expecting sort of a science kind of
which it is like uh
you know
elucidating something about the human
mind kind of thing but you could also
probably write
really strong like novels
uh so maybe that's in the future but
anyway what is your how many edits how
many what's your style does it look like
that is it more structured organized
unfortunately i used a laptop so i
didn't have this sort of uh beautiful
recorder typewriter cigarette
and whiskey i did explore i was you know
which was there a particular altered
state that would help me to be most
creative and and i
i found actually i i actually did the
best while uh you know sober but
slightly disinhibited in the late hours
of the of the night or early morning
yeah particularly late hours of the
night there
you know i i i have a friend who would
tell me that she thought that very early
in the morning her inner critic was
still asleep and she could write more
effectively before her inner critic woke
up yeah and i actually found that uh
outstanding advice for me that i often
found that there was
i was looser and could write more in the
morning
but the other interesting thing is is
each each chapter each story it's about
a different
uh human being with a different class of
of psychiatric disorder that's what each
story each
each chapter is anchored in
by trying to use words that and style
of writing and
and uh you know diction that captures
the feeling of the disorder and so it's
different in each story in the story
about mania
which is a very
expansive exuberant uh
at least briefly uplifting state uh
where the words come out in a torrent
and they're complex and pressured and
elaborate
i try to capture that feeling with the
the words used in that chapter and then
in the schizophrenia or psychosis
chapter where things slowly fragment
over time and become looser and
and and separated i tried to capture
that in the writing too so for each it
wasn't as if there was a single mode i
could be in for the whole book for each
chapter i had to put myself into a
different mode to capture that uh
inner feeling of the disorder when you
put yourself in that mode does that
change you
yeah i couldn't turn it on and off right
away i had to
first i would start by thinking about
the person uh or the people one or two
people based on real patients and the
stories that are that are put forth uh
the symptom descriptions are real
they're from the patients of course all
details change to protect uh privacy but
the actual symptom descriptions are real
and i would sit with them
and really try to inhabit the space of
the mind of of that
person that i knew
and that's not instantaneous it would
take take some time i needed quiet i
needed to be still that's another reason
late at night is is good
sergey posted that drowsiness gives
creativity boosts according to andrew
huberman
thank you andrew
uh it's not wrong he's not wrong why
projections is it uh
i mean there's some
instead of putting words into your mouth
because i can imagine a lot i mean i to
me
you know i will start putting words in
your mouth despite what i just said
so i mean
to me projections working on neural
networks for example from artificial
neural networks from a machine learning
perspective it's often
that's exactly what you're doing you
have an incredibly complex thing and
you're trying to
find simple representations in order for
you to make sense of it so i was kind of
thinking about in that way which is like
um
this incredibly complex
neuronal network
that is kind of
projecting itself onto the world
through this low bandwidth expression of
emotion and speech and all that kind of
stuff and the way
it's
we only have that window into your soul
the eyes and the speech and so on so
that
in that way we're um
when there's any kind of disorder
we get to only see that disorder through
that narrow window as opposed to the
full complexity of its origins the word
projections
definitely serves that purpose here but
it's it's got a few other
really
appropriate other connotations as well
so the first thing is a projection in
terms of neuroscience is
this long-range connection that goes
from one part of the brain to another
and so it's what binds two
parts of our brain together there are
projections long-range connections of
axons these are the outgoing
threads that connect
one part of the brain to another part
there's a there's a projection that
links for example auditory cortex where
we hear things to reward centers where
we can feel where feelings of pleasure
and reward are initiated
and it's been shown that if you have
reduced
connectivity along that dimension you
are less able to enjoy music and so
these connections these projections
matter they define
how effectively two parts of the brain
can engage with each other and join
together to form a joint representation
of something so that's one meaning it's
pure neuroscience the word projection is
used all the time and it happens to be
something that optogenetics a technique
that we maybe we'll talk about a little
later it works particularly well with we
can use light to turn on or off the
activity along these projections from
one spot of the brain to another and
this is particularly referring to the
long range connections it's particularly
straightforward along these long range
projections that connect different parts
of the brain but it works over shorter
range too but then there's this other
meaning of projections which you were
bringing up which is very relevant which
is
at some point you you can reduce
something from one level of
dimensionality to another you can
project down into a lower dimensional
space for example
and then finally there's a psychiatric
uh
term projections which comes up all the
time which is uh
we
very often uh will
look at our internal states and to
understand somebody else we'll
project them on to somebody else we'll
try to understand someone else's
behavior and and make sense of it by
projecting our own inner feelings our
own
uh sort of narrative onto them
and use that as a way to help us
understand them better and we'll do the
reverse too we'll take things we see in
the outside world and we'll bring them
into ourselves and see how well they map
how will they align that's called
introjection so projections is a turns
out to be a really rich word then
finally of course there's the very
common
sense of it as as a projector that that
illuminates by conveying information
across space with
light
so for english for english language
perfect word to use for this book but
what's funny is
not every
there are a lot of international
translations now and and all those rich
connotations aren't captured in other
languages and so for some
translations uh connections is used uh
instead of projections in fact even in
england the british version is
connections instead of projections
because apparently projections doesn't
have the full connotation i was told you
have to sacrifice some of the rich um
ambiguity of meaning
uh with connections that's interesting i
mean connect
and words are so interesting they have
so many i love language and how much is
lost in translation i'm very fortunate
enough to be able to speak i'm not good
at languages i was just i guess
forced to by life circumstance to learn
two languages
russian and english and it's just so
interesting to watch how much of culture
how much of people how much of history
is lost in translation
the poetry the the music
the history the pain the way the
scientists actually express themselves
which is funny i mean just
it's so sad um
to see
how much brilliant work
that was written in russian there's a
whole culture of science
in the soviet union that is now lost it
makes me wonder
in the modern day
how much incredible science is going on
in china
that is lost in translation and i'll
never i mean that makes me very sad
because
i'll never learn chinese in the same way
that i've learned english and in russian
maybe
whenever i say stuff like that people
are like well there's still time but uh
you know uh yeah that's it's that's
actually fair that uh i think the 21st
century
both china and us will have very
important roles in the scientific
development
and
we should actually bridge the gap
through language and that that doesn't
just mean convincing chinese to speak
english
that means also learning chinese well we
need these bridge people who can do both
you know the
um you know nabakov for example writing
in english beautifully uh uh you know
one of my favorite poets porques who you
know mentioned earlier he wrote both in
english and in spanish i think you know
beautifully in both we need those people
who can serve as
bridges across cultures who really can
do both
you mentioned borges so
you open your book with a few lines from
a poem by
jorge luez borges a love poem i'm going
to read parts of it because it's a damn
good poem yeah it's called two english
poems i mean there's i'd like to
understand why you used it and the
specific parts you used which is
interesting but then when i read the
full thing
so i think you used it
as as
a sort of beautiful description of what
it means to delve deep into
understanding
uh offering yourself to the task of
understanding another human being but if
you look at the full context of the poem
it's also a damn good description of
being hit by love and overtaken by it
and uh
uh sort of
and trying to
trying to figure out how to make sense
of the world now that you've been uh
stricken by it
it says a bunch of things
uh about
chatting and significantly with friends
and all those kinds of things and then
the poem reads
the big wave brought you
i get this is the moment
i guess of the universe where the two
people you fall in love maybe i'm
totally misreading this poem by the way
it doesn't matter you can't misread a
poem
so it goes on words any words you're
laughter and you're so lazily and
incessantly beautiful
we talked and you have forgotten the
words
the shattering dawn finds me in a
deserted street of my city your profile
turned away the sounds that go to make
your name the lilt of your laughter
these are the illustrious toys you have
left me
so these little memories of these
peculiar little details he remembers
those are the illustrious toys
i apologize to mix my own words of the
poem but you should definitely read it
i turn them over in the dawn i lose them
i find them i tell them to the few
straight dogs into the few stray stars
of the dawn
your dark rich
life
i must get at you somehow
i put away those illustrious toys you
have left me
i want your hidden look your real smile
that lonely mocking smile your cool
mirror knows
i want your hidden look your real smile
i am so i this is the first part of the
poem and then it goes on which is some
of the parts that you reference
second part is what can i hold you with
i offer you lean streets desperate
sunsets the moon of the jagged suburbs i
offer you the bitterness of a man who
has looked long and long in a lonely
moon
i
offer you my ancestors my dead men the
ghosts the living men have honored in
bronze my father's father killed in the
frontier of buenos aires two bullets
through his lungs and so on so on i
offer you whatever insights my books may
hold whatever manliness of humor my life
i offer you the loyalty of a man who has
never been loyal i offer you that kernel
of myself that i have saved somehow the
central heart that deals not in words
traffics
not with dreams and is untouched by time
my joy and
adversities
and i think this is where the part they
include in the book
i offer you the memory of a yellow rose
cena sunset
years before you were born
i
damn that's a good line okay
[Laughter]
i offer you explanations of yourself
theories about yourself authentic and
surprising news of yourself
i can give you my loneliness my darkness
the hunger of my heart i am trying to
bribe you with uncertainty with danger
with defeat
that is a man who's in love and longing
if i've taken but i just want to go back
to maybe you could say why you want to
include that poem but also
your dark rich life i must get at you
somehow i put away those illustrious
toys you have left me out when you're i
want your hidden look your real smile
that lonely mocking smile your cool
mirror knows what sometimes i meet a
stranger
and i just
it's like it's like a double take
it's like who are you
have we met before somewhere who's that
person behind there
and i want to get at that whatever that
is and of course maybe that's what love
is because maybe
uh maybe that's the whole pursuit like a
lifelong pursuit of getting at that
person maybe that's what that is and
like that uh insatiable sort of
curiosity to keep getting like who's
that person then you're on private life
yeah so that absolutely i think that it
was a beautiful description of what you
just said when there's that first moment
and then you want to dive deeper you
want to know what the what the hidden
mysteries are
in a way it's it's a it's a love poem
as a as a scientist though it also
it's a bit of how a scientist can love
science and and
that
wanting to dive deeper is
it's almost like again where the it
could be a love affair with
investigating the human mind for example
and and that was one reason it spoke to
me also
again thinking about
the broader sweep of where the human
mind came from uh
the steps it took
to get where it is today what was given
up along the way what compromises were
made and here's where the darkness of
the poem starts to come in a little bit
too it doesn't shy away
from the negativity
from
the confusion from the danger
and then at the very end
the board faces offering up
scenes from his life parts of himself
and this is how we connect with people
we offer up parts of ourselves just here
it is and then we see how well does that
map on to what you have and it's it's
that offering up
that i liked and not not the good stuff
or not only the good stuff the yellow
rose is nice but but he's offering up
the bad stuff too
and that that to me was important for
the for the book because
i'm offering up hard stuff too and in
fact a lot of it and also hard stuff
from within me from my my own personal
side too and that was there's a lot of
vulnerability that comes with that but
that's
that comes with love that comes with
writing you have to be open you have to
be vulnerable and so
i thought that reflected what i was
trying to do and i thought it was a as
an epigraph it kind of
made it clear
how vulnerable
i was in taking this step but also
what what could come out of it and also
in a meta way because i was not familiar
with this poem
it uh
it made me curious
of the poem itself to pull at that
thread of finding out more
so you picked a very particular part
that kind of made you want to um
pull at that thread and and then and see
where did this
where did these few lines come from
because i i read it as a curiosity of a
scientist those lines were
alone and also
as a desperate
uh human being
searching like offering himself for an
understanding or connection with with
another human being and then because i
wasn't sure if it's a love poem or not
or if it's desperation or if it's
curious whatever it is and then you see
the love poem i mean i don't know that
that's gonna stick with me for a while
the
your dark rich life
and then a few lines in here are just
i mean those are i'm going to just use
them as as pick up lines at a bar i
offer you the memory of a yellow rose
seen at sunset years before you were
born
now that's a pickup line i've never if
if i've ever heard one anyway sorry but
this is universal you know you see it in
so many forms of of art you know like
you know we're in texas now you see this
in country uh country and western songs
it's it's often a list of things like
here's how i describe myself there's
this and there's that and there's the
other thing and here you are these
things matter to me and i hope they
matter to you too it's a it's a pretty
universal form but it's but he did it in
this very
artful uh
and very
vulnerable way it was it was both both
beautiful and you could you could feel
the hurt coming from him too and that
was important
the dark stuff too i offer you my
ancestors my dead men the ghosts the
living men have honored in bronze and
talking about two bullets through his
lungs bearded and dead
wrapped by his
[Applause]
soldiers in the height of a cow my
mother's grandfather just 24 heading a
charge of 300 men in peru now ghosts
on vanished horses
so all of it the whole history of it
um since it is a love poem
what do you think about love
carl what's what's the role of love in
the human condition we'll talk about the
dark stuff yeah but uh maybe love is the
dark stuff too i mean it's it's the most
powerful
connection we can form and that's that's
it's
that's what makes it so important to us
it's the it's the strongest
and most stable connection that we can
form with another person and that
matters immensely
it matters for
for the human family to
have evolved to be
something that could survive against the
odds that that that we've faced over the
years that
un
reasonable bond that becomes reasonable
by virtue of its own existence
and of course
that joy the the wild raw joy of love is
not a bad thing either
so you put these together
the four the strongest bridge we can
form
and the reward and the joy that that it
brings that's that's what love is to me
and
from you know my perspective this is
something that you know
it can be hard to capture fairly because
you want to talk about
the positive and the negative sides at
once they need to be wrapped up together
for full honest description of what it
is
and that that's hard to do in a in a
compact form and so
you have to take time to talk about love
you have to take time to
to do it justice um it takes a book or
at least a poem
or several thousands of them i don't
know so is there could you pull up
there's a video i saw
yeah like right here so can you pause
for a second
uh so so there's march of the penguins
so you always see like penguins huddling
together
against i i mean sorry if i see just
metaphors and everything but uh them
huddling together against the harshness
of the conditions around them that's
very kind of
that's like a metaphor for life like
finding this connection that's kind of
what love is it's like it allows you to
forget whatever the absurdity whatever
the suffering of life is together you
get to like
huddle for warmth and that's why i love
the uh sort of just the uh the honesty
and the intensity of the way penguins
just in the middle of like the cold do
this and then this video i saw
a lonely this is this is misinformation
so the name of the video is lonely
deranged penguin i don't know if he's
deranged so if you play it
so he left his pack
and uh
and there's a nice like voiceover and
you don't need to play it but he for
some reason left the pack and journeyed
out into the mountains
and so the the narrator says that he's
deranged he's lost his mind
now i'd like to project the idea that
he's actually
there's so many stories you could think
of he's returning to his homeland he's
an outsider thinking journeying out into
the unknown thinking he may be able to
discover something greater than the
tribe he might be looking for a lost
love
why is he deranged immediately why has
he lost his mind anyway but this you
people should look up this video because
to me i might be the only one who uh
romanticizes this but it's such a nice
kind of it's both a picture of perhaps a
mental disorder which is what the video
kind of describes and it may be some
deeper explanation that's not
that that has to do with the motivation
of a
of a mind
yeah i don't know if i don't know if you
have a deeper analysis on this penguin
well i i
like you as a psychiatrist
i i would i would want to sit down with
a penguin and go
i want to see the notes from his prior
therapist and
but
this this actually is
relevant not knowing what was
that penguin's motivation we have
very clear
situations where there are both within
an individual we go through periods of
time when we
stay in one place
and we
reap the benefits from what we've built
and then we go through periods of
foraging of of of wandering even if
there may be resources where we are we
we
have periods of time in our lives where
we want or where we where we
go in an exploratory mode and different
people express that trait in different
ways this is not a human specific trait
if you go down to to the tiny little
nematode worm
c elegans with 302 nervous system cells
they go through these phases of foraging
and rest and different individuals have
different propensity to forage or to
rest and stay in one place
at the level of the species that's
really good
that there's that
diversity in their willingness to forage
some
stay where they are the species is
somewhat on a firm footing then
but some carry a burden
a risk for themselves but
it's good for the species that they're
explorers and they will venture out
the migration patterns that
different species blunder into and that
turn out to be really good they weren't
logically derived
they
most certainly started from
something like this an exploration
humans do this too you think and we do
it too in fact it's that's something we
do extremely well
let's talk about psychiatry a little bit
so my book you're a a rock star first of
all for people who don't know you're one
aside from sort of um
the neurological view of the brain and
neuroscience view of the brain you're
also one of the great psychiatrists of
our time i've always
not always but when i was younger i
dreamed about being a psychiatrist
um
so it's like it's like getting to meet
your heroes
and also um
you know getting to meet the people who
uh
the best
at the top of the world at the thing
you've failed to pursue so there so
there's i'm getting a free therapy
session on top of that okay so what uh
big picture what is the practice the
goal the hope of modern psychiatry if
you could try to describe the discipline
as you see it maybe historically
throughout the 20th century
in contrasting to what it is today or
maybe if you want to describe to what
you hope psychiatry becomes or longs to
become in the 21st century yeah
it's been an interesting journey uh it
psychiatry started out
pretty firmly grounded in neurology and
pathology some of the initial
founders effectively of the field were
very well grounded in microscopy looking
at cells
working with patients uh particularly on
the neurological side and this certainly
included you know freud and some of his
contemporaries
and
but they rapidly discovered that
what they could work with at the level
of
cells and microscopy was so far
from the realm of what they could get
from a human being
and what they were getting from the
human being was so much more interesting
and had was so mysterious and so unknown
that many of them
just said we're going to inhabit this
domain and we're going to work with the
people with their words
and understand what we can
based on verbal communication because
that was the only tool that people
really had
and
that was
a very
important step for the field i would say
one of the interesting things that came
from the early decades of psychiatry
really was this distinction between the
conscious and the unconscious mind
and paying particular attention
to the unconscious mind is something
that was worthy of consideration uh that
that might be important in explaining
people's actions
and that perhaps even insight into that
was valuable in its own right
and out of that psychoanalysis uh
became a practice that
it was not always focused on
cures or treatment but was more focused
on insight what does it what does it
mean how can we help people understand
why they're
feeling something or thinking something
or dreaming something
and that insight separate even from
treatment was was an interesting thing
as long as
one was honest about that and said you
know we're we're going for understanding
we're going for insight maybe it's
useful to just pause on that let's if
you look at the father psychoanalysis
sigmund freud
what do you make of the ideas that he
had so you mentioned
taking the unconscious the subconscious
seriously
that's like step one like that there
could be worlds we do not have direct
access for we
probe at them
through conversation or
um is it too simplistic to call
psychoanalysis conversation that's not
too simplistic but that's right and i
think that was valuable where where
freud ended up breaking from some of his
contemporaries he was very focused on
this unconscious as being so tightly
linked to libido and and really he
from his perspective you couldn't really
separate the operation of the
unconscious mind from these aspects of
the libidinous aspects and that was one
reason
you know sex sexual sexually related uh
you know drives
carl jung who was his you know
uh you know contemporary that's one
factor that led to them separating was
you know carl jung felt there was a lot
more
to the unconscious than than this
libidinous aspect of it and he saw it as
a much more
complete uh
uh alternate representation of the the
conscious self one that maybe reflected
a whole range of different
motivations and and desires
um
and
to to properly treat it one had to
consider all of them rather than the
ones that destroyed us called young chef
thank you
thank you for the high level of uh of
images that sergey is pulling up for
people who are just listening he pulled
up a
as a quote from uh segment four it's a
meme your mom quote uh freud uh so the
the shadow the carl young shadow
encompasses
everything not just the desire to have
sex with your mother
or sex period that's right that's right
if you look at those two folks
on mass i mean there's a kind of
it's almost like a technique for
philosophical exploration of human mind
human motivations
so it's not even like necessarily
it's also doubles as a methodology for
helping people but it's almost like a
it's a kind of philosophical method
right
this is the fascinating thing about
about psychoanalysis and and
it even though it's it's i would say
mostly not considered a treatment today
it persists for a couple reasons one is
it it's it's thought that it gives
people some insight
but
second there's been a huge influence on
on literature on philosophy on art
and the the opening up of discussion
about what was
below our conscious mind was uh so so
fertile in the implications that it it
sort of reverberated and still does
throughout all these different realms of
human endeavor from
our
different artistic
uh you know
experiences that people have can be
colored by this this uh
concept of the unconscious
now the other thing that was interesting
is is is this distinction
you know what what are the parts of the
unconscious and and so there were these
id and ego and superego uh
subdivisions that
you know that that freud for example
would would talk about them and and the
the id was the primary the primal drives
that an infant would have uh or that a
very young child just warmth and feeding
and then then later the you know the
sexual or libidinous aspects and for
freud the later happened very quickly
that's the controversial thing about him
i think i guess he thought like even
children had sexual desires that they're
like dealing with contending with so
it's the full thing hungry wanting to
eat wanting to poop wanting to have sex
yeah and he was extremely focused on
that on on that aspect
but then there was then there was this
the superego which brought on these
later sort of moralistic uh
sort of codes of conduct and and that of
course was very often in intention but
all this could play out subconsciously
and then the ego
this third aspect was mediating and for
its conception mediated this tension
between the different uh parts
now i think that's interesting uh i will
say that
in some ways
it's maybe unnecessary
from the perspective of modern
neuroscience to divide things up that
way from the you know the moralistic
drives and the primal
gratification drives
in some ways they're all drives and
maybe they're even all primal drives you
know the the moralistic drives they're
they're taught and they're taught in
ways that ultimately relate back to
survival and
you could even say selfish aspects of
of health and life for the self and
family and
so this is uh i don't i think it's maybe
an artificial distinction the concept of
the unconscious is very valuable and
very interesting um but
these categorizations
uh of id and and uh superego may not
map onto neurobiology in any particular
way if there's a town hall of competing
drives and desires and there
they
interrelate to each other they involve
different aspects of the of the brain
and the history of the person
and actions and choices come out of the
result of that overall you know shouting
in the town hall so in some sense carl
jung was a step into the direction of
liberating yourself from such harsh
categorizations
do you think
i mean you have daniel kahneman with
system one of system two
there's just these very compelling
categorizations of the human mind that
seemed to be
sticky
in our uh
in the super ego no uh in the you know
the how we talk about these ideas and so
on yeah do you think those are helpful
or do they get in the way is it some
kind of balance in terms of deeper
understanding of how the mind actually
works you know it's from the from modern
neuroscience uh
whenever we
seem to get closer to
addressing a question like this at the
level of cells
it seems to get farther away and i'll
give you an example of what i mean by
that so one thing i'm doing in my
laboratory and many people are doing is
we are listening in on the activity of
cells neurons in the brain of mice or
rats or fish or monkeys individual cells
individual cells exactly of which there
are you know in our brain many billions
and
when we do and we
try to predict what action will be taken
by an animal
to address this question where does
the choice arise where does the
impetus to make a particular selection
of one action versus another action
where does that start in the brain if
you're recording listening in on the
activity of cells all across the brain
where's the earliest spot you can pick
up
a choice being made
well that's so awesome
yeah at one level you might think how
excited would young have been to see
this or freud or the early you know
psychoanalysts to see where this starts
but it's not so simple because
an emerging theme in very recent
neuroscience literally over the last few
years
is that
things sort of all start together all
across the brain and so you can be
recording from the cortex this rim of
cells at the surface of the brain or you
can be recording deeper in a structure
called the striatum which is a little
older
it's more tightly linked to to action
and then structures called the thalamus
other parts of the brain and if you
record from these these
all sort of
represent the action and the choice
more or less all at about the same time
very close and so it's you can't point
to a particular spot
and say here's where
the choice or the action originates it's
a
finding the free will neuron
that's relevant to that question nobody
is is close to being able to point to
such a thing well close
is a relative term
and nobody
uh what i what i tweet today uh all
generalizations are wrong
[Laughter]
so including this one let's actually
talk about that sort of the study of
individual cells
if you could linger on your
sense that as you get closer to that
understanding it feels like you're
getting farther away
why is that because that that often is
the feeling until you're actually there
so
so like uh you know see that's when i'm
running
and i know there's only a mile left it
just feels like that mile is just
getting longer and longer but eventually
you finish so maybe we're getting close
to cracking open these like beginnings
of ascent like we'll talk about
consciousness or these very difficult
big
questions about the human mind where do
they start
you're right to say we shouldn't uh
generalize or make absolutist statements
but i would say
right now the reason things are looking
even
harder to crack than we had initially
thought
we now have the data streams that we've
wanted for so long
in terms of activity patterns all across
the brain at the level of cells we can
literally see
what cells are doing
immense data sets you know we get
these are you know time series of one
individual cell with you know sub second
resolution and you can collect this from
you know enormous numbers of cells
across the brain
so very rich data sets that we've wanted
for a long time and yet having these
uh has not led
to
an understanding of truly where actions
uh initiate um in terms of regions or
locations let's get a few questions on
that is the answer
high-level
question by your intuition
is the answer within the data or do we
need
different kind of data so we should also
say that when you collect data about the
the brain there's like the richness of
information you're collecting
but there is also human doing stuff
um like
and the information so static
information about the human and dynamic
information about the human and you can
get them to do different stuff and you
can select different humans
and that's part of the collection of
data aspects so like when you're
collecting data about the brain
there's some truths
that you can you know in machine
learnings like annotations like
supervised learning there's some true
things you can hold on to before you
look at the full
rich mess complexity of the human
mind so given the data you've looked at
do you think the answer
for the for the origin of free will in
the human mind is can be found
well
one one
amazing thing is that
nobody's nobody's found it but we have
these rich data sets and and then
there's a conundrum which is
uh is it in the data and we just don't
know how to look at it maybe we don't
know the right scale the right
projection to make of the data the right
way to interpret it
and here's where
causal testing becomes very valuable
because then instead of just passively
observing
well here are
here are the activity patterns and then
here's the choice made by the animal
as we've gotten more
powerful at reaching in and causing
things to happen in the brain turning up
or down
the activity of certain types of cells
or defined populations of cells and
seeing how that affects actions these
causal perturbations have turned out to
be very valuable
we're just now getting to the point
where we can apply these in very
wide
swaths of the brain at cellular
resolution and so we're going to be able
uh hopefully to make some headway on
this question with with causality and
those that's
the one thing that optogenetics provides
us this way of using light that we
develop to control cells
this
is an untapped relatively untapped at
this broad brain wide scale and
hopefully we can get there in the near
future but i would say that the answer
may be maybe in the data uh but we don't
know how to find it
well there's this interactive element
like where you can cause stuff that's
really powerful because you get to
i mean
uh as opposed to collecting data
passively you you're collecting data
actively so can you maybe describe
one of the many things you're known for
one of one of the big things is called
optogenetics what is it
optogenetics is a way of causing things
to happen it's a way of
determining what what actually matters
in terms of the activity of the brain
for
the amazing things it does
sensation cognition action
and what it does is it provides activity
it's a way of playing in if you will
activity patterns into precisely defined
cells and the way we do it is pretty
cool i think it's you know
right away there's a problem if you
think about how do we do this how could
we play in well-defined activity
patterns and provide a stream of of
activity
into this cell and that cell and that
cell but not these other cells so just
for for context we're talking about the
brains of mice
uh
monkeys
humans
and then the goal is to try to control
accurately the behavior of a single
neuron and then to be able to monitor
a single
collection of single neurons to then say
well to draw some deeper insight about
the
origins first of all the function of
different parts of the brain different
neurons different kinds of neurons but
also the origins of the big things the
uh the the flap of the butterfly wing
that leads to an actual behavioral
thing yeah so if you could exactly so if
you could turn on or off
the brain or parts of the brain or cell
types or individual cells
at the
natural rate and rhythm and timing of
normal brain activity
that would be immensely valid because
you could determine what actually
mattered what what could cause complex
things to happen and what could prevent
complex things from happening in a
specific way
but right away you've got a problem if
you want to do this and and scientists
neuroscientists have wanted to do this
for a long time francis crick of double
helix of dna fame he wrote a
famous paper in 1999 he got interested
in neuroscience later in life
and he said
what we need
in neuroscience is a way that we could
turn on or off
the activity of individual types of
neurons
in a behaving animal
and he even said
the ideal signal would be light because
it would be fast it could uh
penetrate through the
brain to some extent
and
he had no idea how to do it he said this
would probably be very far-fetched but
it would be a good thing and so that's
what you're actually saying like if you
want to do this kind of thing
and then
it's you imagine like how do i get
inside the brain it's pretty difficult
it's very difficult and then even once
you get in it's hard because all brain
cells are electrical all neurons are
electrically activated and so if you
wanted to use electricity
as what you were putting in
you won't have any specificity at all if
you have an electrode a wire and you put
it in the brain and you send current
through it all
the cells near the electrode will be
stimulated it's like trying to control
fish by spraying them with water
yeah right because there's already a lot
of
electricity going around anyway and
you're adding more but there's no
uh specificity even among the different
kinds of cells either because all around
the wire that you've put in they're
going to be so many different cells
doing totally different things many of
them in opposition to each other we know
that's one way the brain is set up there
are parts of the brain that
where neurons side by side are doing
completely different things and maybe
even antagonistic to each other
so what do you do how do you play in
activity with any kind of specificity
well
what you do is use what we found is what
what you can do is
make
some cells responsive to light now
normally
no cells deep in the in the brain really
respond to light they're not built for
that there's no reason for them to
respond to light in there
which is a great situation to start with
because any light sensitivity you can
provide to some cells will be a huge
signal above the noise
and so that's that's what we do with
optogenetics we take
genes bits of dna from
microbes single-celled organisms
and these single-celled organisms like
algae they
make uh little proteins that sit in the
surface of their cells
that receive light capture a photon of
light
and open up a little hole in the
membrane of the cell and let charged
particles ions like sodium and potassium
flow across the membrane of the cell
and that they these algae and bacteria
they do this for their own reasons
because that helps them move it helps
them
make and use energy
but that's a beautiful thing for
neuroscience because movement of ions
charged particles across the membrane of
the cell is exactly the kind of
electricity that neurons work with so if
we can take this
bit of dna
that encodes this beautiful protein that
turns light into electricity from algae
and if we can put it into
some neurons but not other neurons which
we can do using genetic tricks
then you've got a situation then you can
shine on the light
and only
the cells that have the gene and that
are expressing the gene
will be the initial direct cells that
are activated by the light and so that's
the essence of optogenetics is the
ability to do that we get that initial
specificity that you could never get
with an electrode okay so let me say
that this is uh we recently got uh the
alaska prize for this
is a brilliant idea
um
so
i talked to um andrew huberman who's a
friend of yours friend of mine
um
not to jinx things but he believes that
he deserves the nobel prize for this so
um
i do too but what uh my votes
anyway the thing is does it doesn't
matter prizes will be all forgotten all
of us will be forgotten one of the cool
ideas cool idea is a cool idea that's a
really powerful idea it's actually the
the origins of it you might be
interested in are even are very deep uh
there was a botanist in saint petersburg
named andrei fomensen
in 1866
he published a paper
on the single-celled green algae and he
was the botanist who first noticed that
they moved in response to light these
are tiny single-celled algae that have
flagella so they swim through the water
and
he noticed this he was a botanist and he
published this it was as a paper you
know he wrote in
in german but he published it in a
french journal and he was doing it from
st petersburg so it was a very
international effort
but you have to go back to 1866 and that
i just i like to highlight how far back
the that
discovery goes is back to to andre
feminism and this is a
it highlights the value of just pure
basic science discovery that always
originates uh somewhere in the eastern
european bloc uh but i don't think he uh
expected the splicing of genetic
material from into the human brain and
one of the cool things we've been able
to do now with modern methods is to
really study these these proteins and so
we we've discovered some of these
proteins other other groups have as well
we've dived deep into their structure
just like the double helix structure of
dna was uncovered with x-ray
crystallography we used the same method
x-ray crystallography to see how these
beautiful little
proteins work we re-engineered them for
all kinds of function we can make them
instead of responding to blue light we
can make them respond to red light
we can speed them up slow them down we
can make them
with genetic engineering we can make
them have different ions flow through
them
and so it's it's this convergence as you
said like the botanist in 1866 couldn't
have predicted what we could do with
this uh and and the fact that we've been
able to discover how these beautiful
proteins work and then
uh apply them to neuroscience is really
a thrilling story is it possible to
achieve scale do you think with this
meaning
like greater like what is the progress
of the next 50 years 100 years looks
like in terms of the precision and the
scale of control of using light it's
going so fast it's hard to to predict
i'll i'll give you a sense of it though
in
you know first paper you know
we published
in 2005 that was just in cultured
neurons by 2007 so that was in a dish by
2007 we had it working in behaving mice
by 2009 we had a pretty general so we
had methods to really make it a
versatile method could be applied to
essentially any cell
by 2012 we could get to single cell
resolution we used light guidance
strategies to target individual cells in
the brain of a of a living mouse
by
2019
we were able to control up to
20 to 50 individually specified single
cells in the brain of a mouse and in
ways that specifically changed its
behavior that could bias its decisions
one way or the other in fact
we could take a a mouse and
without any visual stimulus at all we
could make it act as if it had seen a
particular visual stimulus by playing in
using the single cell resolution
optogenetics a specific pattern of
activity into you know 20 or 25
individually specified cells that's 2019
it's your question of scale now in 2022
we're controlling hundreds of
individually specified single cells
over
all of visual cortex of a mouse all the
part of the of the
of the brain that that is the initial
direct target of the incoming
information from the from the retina are
you constrained to specific types of
cells currently like you mentioned long
range is a little easier is there
constraints on which cells uh now there
really isn't now that we have this
individual cell guidance we can target
any individual kind of cell very
reliably
and
so now to your question of scale
uh
how far can we go well
things are moving quickly it's hard to
say uh we we can access individual cells
across the entire brain now
if you look 10 20 years in the future um
you know i think we'll
we'll surprise ourselves but the fact
that we're already able to yeah to cause
specific perceptions to happen and
specific actions means we're essentially
where we want to be and now it's a
matter of
just uh
you know
more experiments more discoveries but
the the basic
principles are clear now the basic
capabilities is there is there a pathway
to doing
the same for humans
optogenetics is primarily it's a
discovery tool it really is well suited
for use in mice and rats and and monkeys
because it's uh
it involves putting in a gene
uh and also delivering light and those
are two things that you can do in human
beings but you'd want to do in a very
careful way now that that said there is
actually just less than a year ago um my
friend bhoton raska in switzerland
he did the first human optogenetics
uh
therapy and he published this in the
journal nature medicine so about
uh
10 12 years ago he and i published a
paper together where
we gave him one of our
optogenetic tools one of these
light-activated
regulators of ion flow
these are called microbial opsins by the
way opsins
and he put one of those into an
extracted retina from a human being
who had died so it was a catavaric
retina and he was able to show that
optical control in this in this paper
uh was able to turn on or off individual
cells in the human retina so that was a
while back
he spent about 10 years of going through
all the regulatory
you know hoops and hurdles and going
through primate studies and finally he
was able to take a human being
with a retinal degeneration syndrome so
someone who's blind in both eyes
and he gave a one of these options
into
one eye of this human being
who was blind
and
with the goal of conferring light
sensitivity onto this retina that
was not able to see light
and he was able to to make this person
see through that eye so he took a blind
person and the blind person could could
see now could reach for objects
selectively on a table uh
and
he published this in nature medicine and
it was
you know that's an amazing thing um do
you know the title of the pit what's his
name again uh roska r-o-s-k-a
can you look up the nature paper yeah
nature medicine
nature medicine so that that's sort of
proof of principle now the retina is
very accessible it's near the surface
you can use natural light or you can use
brighter natural light
i'm myself
i see optogenetics as as a discovery
tool it's a way to figure out the
principles by which the brain works and
how it operates partial recovery of
visual function in a blind patient after
optogenetic therapy so he went through
the full process of
doing primate societies and then and
then going well that's dedication and
that that's really exciting to see yeah
as beautiful as that is and i'm glad he
did all that work
there there are so many other ways that
optogenetics could help with therapies
once you know the principles
then any kind of therapy can become more
powerful once you know the causal cells
in a symptom
like
in lack of motivation or inability to
enjoy things or altered sleep or altered
energy
once you know the cells that are causal
then you can make medications that
address those cells you could address
brain stimulation treatments that might
address those cells also diagnosis
very effective systematic way of
diagnosing or at least providing you
rich
data to some of these deep questions
about schizophrenia about bipolar
all those kinds of things that are
the tools are low resolution currently
for determining what like the degree to
which you have a thing and whether you
have a thing at all
yeah and exactly and so the the hope is
you know that's a this is a great
example of how you can cure or you can
you know provide some relief for a
symptom of a person who has a serious
degenerative disease
but
but the principles are what what we're
after and
that's why i spend even though i'm a
psychiatrist even though i i still see
patients i'm not myself trying to drive
any clinical trials in the lab i'm
trying to discover
and then
any kind of therapy could result from
that
what do you think about
uh
my friend elon musk and his efforts with
neuralink so this is another
i mean there's a lot of things to say
here because there's a lot of ideas
under the umbrella of neuralink
but one of them is to use electrical
signals to stimulate and then
you also record you collect electrical
signals from the brain at a higher and
higher resolution
and you go
implant
surgically
the methods by which you do the
stimulation and the the data collection
so it's possible for the ideas of
optogenetics to play well with this
and we can even zoom out outside of just
neural link and just the whole idea of
brain computer interfaces
what are your thoughts
well i think the engineering that
they've done is actually pretty cool so
i i like the uh robots yeah from the
from the design perspective and it
wasn't a it was a design approach that
wasn't being taken in academia
and it's great that they did it and i
think it's it's pretty cool um so i'll
say that
also there are many ways that you can
record from many thousands of neurons
and that's not the only way it's a it's
a very interesting way
we and others are using uh
brain penetrating electrodes that
actually get quite deep this whole
structure the brain is very interesting
we there's the surface cortex where it's
the most recently
emergent part of the brain in evolution
uh
mammals have it reptiles have something
a little bit like it but it's not really
the full thing
it's a this is a very recent thing
that's what we can access with some of
these you know like the neural link
approach and with some of these short
electrodes
this part of the brain the cortex is
only a few millimeters thick there's so
much that's deep though that's so
important there's the striatum there's
the thalamus there are the parts of the
brain that
drive
motivation that drive hunger and thirst
and and social interaction and parenting
and
and flight and fear and anxiety all
these things are there's so much that's
deep that these surface approaches are
not getting to and so we and others are
using these very long
electrodes that help us get deep and we
can still record for many cells many
thousands of cells
we can have multiple of these at once in
the same animal
and so there's a diversity of methods to
get to this goal um i think it's great
that that people coming from you know
the you know outside academia will bring
ideas that weren't being worked on uh at
least approaches they may turn out to be
synergistic
these things work very do work very well
with optogenetics because all these
electrical recording
methods
that's one channel of information flow
light delivery is a separate you know
more or less independent there can be
some some artifacts that happen but if
you're careful that it's another
independent
pathway of information flow
and we've done
really fun experiments in mice where we
play in patterns of activity with light
and we record activity from all across
the brain of a mouse electrically and so
using optical and electrical together is
extremely uh powerful so like opto
electric brain computer interfaces
which by the way there's uh efforts on
the computing side to build optoelectric
uh servers so like where you have both
electricity so because optics is really
interesting light is a very interesting
method of communication that's like you
said orthogonal many ways
it doesn't have some of the constraints
of bandwidth that electricity does going
through wires
but
you're able to but it's less ability to
control precisely at scale
so like there's challenges and there's
benefits and having those two interplay
is really really really fascinating
especially when obviously on the other
side
of your signal is a biological
um
[Music]
well the the mushy mesh is kind of
interesting because we we have there are
problems with light light scatters in
the brain so the the photons don't just
go you know linearly through they
whenever they hit an interface between
fat and water lipid and water
they they bounce off in different
directions and so you can come in with
all the resolution you want you could
play in an incredibly detailed high
resolution pattern of light but the
photons start scattering uh quite
quickly and by the time you've gone a
couple millimeters deep you've lost
almost all that fine spatial information
so
but we've developed workarounds the
longer wavelength light you use if you
get into the infrared there's less
scattering you can use two photon
methods or three photon methods where
the photons have to arrive all together
at the same time
you can put in fiber optics we developed
these fiber optic methods in 2007 where
you can access these deep structures
with fiber optic methods and you can put
many of these fiber optics at the same
time in an animal we've used holographic
methods
3d holograms to play in
hundreds of individual cell sized spots
of light and we can and we can change
those quickly and so there are a lot of
tricks a lot of interesting optics
engineering that has come together with
neuroscience in a pretty exciting way
but it's engineering too it was just
super super super exciting i should
mention because i remember mentioning
elon
um i recently got
for the first time ever
got covered
um
how did i go so long
without finally so i'm all vaccinated
and everything like that and so i got uh
because i think he he mentioned it
publicly so i can mention it but i won't
mention anybody else involved but
hanging out we've all got you and got
covered and the interesting thing about
maybe you can comment about this so i
was only sick for like a half a day i
got a fever of like 104 i just went up
and then crashed and then i was
now maybe i'm just seeing the silver
lining of everything but
afterwards
uh
i have like a greater clarity about the
world
you just think it's greater clarity
maybe maybe i just it was so
uh maybe so intensely
the
mind fog kind of thing for such a short
amount of time but the people were
involved were also reporting this it's
kind of interesting it's like uh because
i i do know
like the immune system
uh is involved with the brain in very
interesting ways so like the human mind
also incorporates all these other it's
not just the
it's it's not just the nervous system
and i i just want it because everyone
always says no not like everyone always
says lykova does all these bad things or
whatever the disease is or whatever the
virus but i wonder like i hate to be a
stephen pinker on this but like i wonder
what the benefits of certain diseases
are if you're able to recover
like what is there some like uh again
don't want to romanticize it but if your
system goes to some kind of hardship and
you come out on the other end i wonder
sometimes if there's a greater um maybe
killed off a bunch of neurons that i
didn't need anyway and they were
actually getting in the way there were
the hater neurons well that was your
inner critic that i was talking exactly
killed off your critic well you know
there are mechanisms for what the
potential mechanisms for what you're
talking about
there are uh there's actually been a
fair bit of research on
post-covered
neurological
function and actually my wife michelle
mange who's at stanford she's done a lot
of this work uh akiko iwasaki yale has
done a lot of this
but what what they found is that
there's a loss of myelin this is the
coating of those long range projections
that go from one part of the brain to
another myelin is this sort of insulator
that coats these long-range projections
and makes the impulses go faster and
more reliably
and there's altered
function of the myelin producing cells
uh an altered myelin in
the case of of covert they've looked in
both mouse and and human brains
and
but of course it could be very
idiosyncratic
many people have cognitive problems
postcoded you're definitely aware of
that so many people report this
persistent brain fog inability to
function
but it depends on where the inflammation
was you know maybe the people who have
dysfunction
postcode they had a global effect
maybe you
lost some of these projections that were
restraining you in some way and and
these plausibly exist and it's known
that there are
cell populations in the prefrontal
cortex that actively restrain
deeper structures from expressing what
they do
and it's it's theoretically possible
that you had a lucky
uh somebody has to get lucky right
somebody has to get like
all right if we can actually uh go back
to
this idea of trying
through optogenetics
to find origins of
when the wave first starts
origins of a decision
origin of
uh idea
origin of maybe
consciousness or
the subjective experience the origin of
things in the mind
uh so one thing it's carl jung
um is there a god neuron
is there a belief neuron
is there so through this methodology of
optogenetics can you start
getting
to like where
a belief
begins or an idea begins
and especially looking at the strongest
of our beliefs maybe beliefs of love and
hate but
religious belief into some something
like really
grand
on the grandest of scale
neuroscience
and
uh neurology point us a little bit uh we
don't have an answer to that but yeah a
lot of these questions i'm going to ask
you there's no good answer but they're
you're providing the tools that give us
hope to find the answer one day yeah and
we have early clues so for example
when patients with epilepsy have
uh experiences of religiosity as part of
their seizure or the aura before their
seizure
very often those are uh in the in the
temporal lobe uh in these parts of the
brain that are
at the side
and so that's initial
clue
there are also
parts of the brain that
are involved in the
definition of the self
uh and defining the borders or
boundaries of the self
and
we know this there's just some
experiments that we did in my lab
there's a part of the brain where if
there's a rhythm
of a particular type you can cause a
separation of the sense of
self
from the sense of the body
what's normally bound up and unitary we
normally think of ourself in our body as
is pretty tightly bound up together
those can be separated it turns out we
can't take that for granted and there
are certain conditions certain patterns
of activity in
one part of the brain called the
retrosplenial cortex where you can
actually separate those two out and so
if you think about
these very big questions
you know what is
where are the origins of religiosity
where how do we define the boundaries of
who we are relative to others and to the
world
how do we link
our self to our body and how can that
become separated these are actually
believe it or not now
accessible and rigorously and
quantitatively so we did an experiment
with optogenetics where we provided
this abnormal rhythm
to this particular part of the mouse
brain and we saw this separation of
detection of a stimulus
and
caring about it so that's that's like
stimulating something about the model's
brain that affects these
neurons that give the conception of self
so you're able to dissociate the
experience from the impact of the
experience unto you that's right exactly
right
so like these are the goals of
meditation
uh these are the goals whenever i get
drunk pretty much effective i mean
that's not a scientific statement just
an experiential anecdotal one um also
psychedelics seek to this
uh to attain this kind of state that's
so interesting well you mentioned
psychedelics you know dmt and five meow
dmt these these create this religious
experience this connection people
describe them as a strong connection to
god
in theory these are accessible with with
modern methods we we now that we have
these rich uh recording methods
we can explore what are the
precise
millisecond resolution cellular
resolution
brain wide
manifestations of these altered states
so
like you could uh look at an altered
state like an on dmt
record it across many people
and then from there see where do these
experiences originate in the brain in
terms of single neurons
and then
how do they how do they propagate and
interact with everything else and if
there's some kind of
uh common
signal like how do you
narrow down the set of neurons that are
responsible for particular experience or
for a particular behavioral effect yeah
here's where optogenetics is so useful
because any time you give an agent like
a you know an agent like
ketamine or pcp which we used for our
dissociation experiments that i was
mentioning or you have a psychedelic
lsd or dmt
for this uh altered perceptual state
if you
if you give either of those these
change everything across the brain okay
so just just the fact that you maybe
give them to a mouse let's say or
eventually to a human
you won't know
yet
which cells to hone in on as the causal
players in all this just by recording
the activity
but then what we found is that
optogenetics providing a causal pattern
of activity guided by what you see
can let you test hypotheses and we saw
this rhythm
with ketamine and pcp for dissociation
and then we said okay let's test what's
causal
we came in and provided that rhythm we
tried a few different things but only
one of the causal tests we tried
actually caused the behavioral
dissociation
and so that's how we hone in on what
actually and is it repeatable once you
see the cause so like that's one
definition of causality is like you try
and repeats across different mice and
all that kind of stuff exactly
and so you could do that for dmt you
could do that for like the really
fascinating mind expanding uh uh
thank you
thank you for so the meme for people
just listening this is again another
disagreement between freud and and uh
uh carl jung religion and spirituality
this is the i guess the ring scene from
uh
lord of the rings religion spirituality
freud says cast it into the fire destroy
it
carl jung says
no so so for people who don't know
sergey is
the slavic lord of the meme thank you i
appreciate that
so what we're talking about so do there
is i mean i think a connection between
gmt and religious experiences or some of
these psychedelics do you think it's
possible to
sort of stimulate religious experiences
so religious experiences are one of the
most
deep kind of experiences and so here you
could
first understand
where they originate
how they propagate to the brain
and then to stimulate them yeah
yeah
and so this is and these that can happen
in
people who had no predisposition um
you know people who who are
you know as agnostic or atheistic as
you'd like uh they can have these they
can feel connected to god in these in
these states
now to be clear i'm not advocating these
we don't know what's safe uh in human
beings but we definitely
have not yet but we definitely can do
these experiments in in mice and that
was already
very productive in understanding
dissociation so we can already imagine
making headway on these methods
and then you know i had a and this this
does map on to the non
psychedelic human experience i had a
patient
who's actually described in in the book
projections this was the patient that's
in the mania chapter the bipolar chapter
here was a guy who had never had a
psychiatric illness or symptom in his
life he was a retirement age gentleman
and
nobody in his family either so no family
history no personal history of any
psychiatric illness and he had never
been religious particularly before
either certainly no no passionate you
know uh type of religion
but he
not through any psychedelic or drug he
he had a stressful experience actually a
post 9 11
change in how he was thinking and he was
pushed into a mania a manic state
revealing that he had bipolar never
before known in this case in this person
and his mania his elevated state and
bipolar included this profound
religiosity he
which he had never had before and he was
he was you know
preaching in a
elevated you know vigorous way to his
family and so this this state
can be created and people even late in
life who had no predisposition for it
and know
even without a neurochemical so
there's the the the causality of that is
very interesting to explore how did the
the manic state
unleash this religiosity but you see
that in other realms of of psychiatry
too ocd
can manifest as religiosity also you can
take people who never really had a
a
religion ever played a powerful role in
their life
but then when their
obsessive compulsive symptoms become
severe they can manifest in this i think
i'm in that group so i'm a bit ocd
we have uh
there's i think this is subreddits uh
one is oddly satisfying things
so there's certain things that are
really satisfying to my ocd in my mild
ocd i think it's pretty much a religious
experience
so i understand that there's it if it's
not direct it's at least uh rhymes
so maybe can you speak to the
sergey is probably uh desperately
scrambling to pull up oddly satisfying
thank you uh people can check it out
themselves it is as as the subreddit
promises oddly satisfying
um can we talk about
bipolar
it may be depression
well let's talk about i mean i don't
know if there's a
a nice way to discuss the differences in
the full landscape of suffering
that's here but maybe what is depression
and
what are the types of depression what
kind of depression
have you
seen and experienced and researched and
how can people overcome it how can
humans overcome it and deal with it live
within overcome it
so this is my clinical
specialty i see patients in my
outpatient clinical work with
treatment resistant depression so very
hard to treat severe illness where
medications haven't been been working i
also see patients with
autism spectrum disorders these are my
two
clinical
focal areas
but then i do emergency room work
as well
but
the depression
why do i focus on that it's so uh
one feels tantalizingly close to helping
these
uh people who are suffering
so deeply that's and that's why i
focused on it is
these are people who
there may not even be anything
situational that's that's difficult or
challenging in their life you can have
people who
seem to have have everything that you
would want every objective measure of
the life is fine and yet they can be
just
hit with this
unstoppable
hopelessness and inability to see into
the future
a
discounting of the value of their own
action anything they
can imagine themselves doing seems
worthless or they
are unable to enjoy things we call this
anhedonia there's no reward no pleasure
not in food
social interaction movies books
anything that they would enjoy
positivity gone
they can have a profound
negative internal state psychic pain
and these things can seem and
in the severe cases are inescapable
so what is going on why why is this
state part of the human existence it's
got a strong
biological genetic link we know that
it's been linked to certain genes
certain regions of the chromosome and
twin studies there's a clear genetic
link
it doesn't explain everything but it's a
big part of it genetics are a strong
contributor
and although you can have depression
without anything terrible going on in
your life the symptoms can be made worse
by stressors by trauma
and
but at a very deep level
there's nothing we can measure in a
person objectively so we don't have
there's not a known
chemical not a known structure
that's different not a known brain
activity pattern that we can pick up
with eeg
a lot of people are exploring this but
right now we have no objective measures
all we do is talk to people and we
elicit these symptoms
we explore them
distinguish them from other possible
causes
and then what do we do
well we have a range of treatments we
have medications that
can help people do help people but not
everybody um
and if they don't work then we can go to
brain stimulation methods we can do
things even like electroconvulsive
therapy which is uh a very effective but
it's that's a sort of the final thing we
go to in the end
and
so we have treatments they they work uh
for some people they don't do everything
we'd like but here's the problem is at a
very deep level
we don't understand really what's going
on in the brain we don't have a physical
interpretation of the problem
we have all these symptoms
but we can't yet point to a set of cells
or a set of circuits or an activity
pattern that is causing major depression
this disease state per se in human
beings
why do you think you can't yet from an
optogenetics perspective is it because
there's so many possible causes is it so
much so many things involved
so i think the answer is there are many
things involved and all these different
symptoms that i've mentioned
those we can study and those we can fix
the individual symptoms and we can do
this in animals to be clear so in a
mouse for example we can instantaneously
and precisely
turn up or down
the motivation of an animal to overcome
a challenge we can turn up or down its
ability
to to to be motivated by or we think
experience reward
from from uh
situations or actions
we can increase its apparent energy
level it's it's uh it's it's its drive
uh to meet challenges
we can turn up or down social
interaction uh
all these individual features of
depression individual symptoms we now
can point to exact
projections and cells
that are causal in mediating these but
we don't know is why
all these different symptoms show up
together
in major depression in the human disease
syndrome and that's that's the mystery
it's sort of
in other fields of medicine you know
someone with congestive heart failure
who comes into the clinic they have very
different symptoms they have shortness
of breath and they have swollen feet
okay couldn't be too
more different
across the body
sets of symptoms
neither one obviously related to the
heart but they're both happening because
the heart is not working as a pump okay
and and now
thankfully in cardiology
we understand these disparate symptoms
that seem totally unrelated
can be completely understood because
there's an altered pump action of the
heart that's that's what we are hoping
for in in psychiatry and in the study of
depression or any disease
these different symptoms the inability
to enjoy things
the hopelessness
uh what's the what's the unifying
unifying i mean is there is there some
truth to that the tolstoy quote
that all happy families are alike and
each unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way so basically
i mean this is the human condition
and and it basically that might you know
the physicists long define the theory of
everything
it doesn't understanding depression
essentially
require you to really have the big
theory of everything for the human mind
i think we
it would certainly be nice to have a
theory of everything don't get me wrong
i don't think we need a first date
of the century it would be nice
it's also a good question if it's
possible yeah yeah well that that i i
have uh some thoughts on too but but to
your to this specific question um i
don't think we need a theory of
everything i think there will be
unifying principles principles we can
get to but even shy of that if we can we
can treat symptoms and that's a big step
and as you say different different
unhappy families are different different
unhappy people are different
if we have somebody who comes to the
clinic and i see someone with a profound
anhedonia as one of their main symptoms
inability to enjoy things and if i know
based on optogenetics work and animal
work that a particular medication
can treat anhedonia even if it doesn't
fix major depression in everybody if i
treat that one symptom in that one
person
that's a good thing
and and so i we don't need
the theory of everything and we don't
even need the unifying principle to help
people with insights that come from
optogenetics
so how much does talking help
for diagnosis and for treatment
would you say for depression
it's a big part of what we do every good
psychiatrist is
should be pretty adept in
these verbal communications and talk
therapy as part of what they do
i give medications i deliver brain
stimulation treatments but
a big big part of everything i do with
every patient is
talk therapy because it works so well
together with
these other modalities even alone it can
help people with moderate or
or mild depression by itself
people with severe depression people
with other
psychiatric illnesses that are are
severe
you don't want to do talk therapy alone
that's not going to do it but it still
is crucial to do together with the
others and it's it's it's critical
because
it's uh part of how you re shape
cognitions you know
complex activity patterns and and you
won't get to that with a medication or
brain stimulation treatment
do you have advice for people who suffer
from mild forms of depression
or feel
as they might
both for those people and do you have
advice for people
who
love the people who suffer from
depression and want to help yeah
one of the incredibly
frustrating things about depression is
the very nature of it
makes it hard for the people who suffer
to
get treatment because they they're
hopeless so they don't think treatment
will help they have low energy
so they're not motivated to participate
in treatment in many cases
they're sometimes they're actively
suicidal that certainly doesn't help
they have all these things that
seem to prevent
treatment from being effective so the
loved ones that's where the loved ones
are so important is is helping them
overcome these barriers to treatment the
motivation the safety
and the insight
that's critical uh
and particularly for the severe cases
for the mild cases where people still
have you know
have some insight and motivation and
energy to get something done
there are many things you can do
uh
exercise is extremely important in in
mood maintenance
regulation of sleep and getting
sufficient and regular enough sleep is
very important
and talk therapy can be helpful in those
mild or moderate cases just looking at
cognitions looking at patterns of
thought
that
people may have fallen into
where they catastrophize where they
spiral from small things into big things
a little bit of talk therapy 10 12
sessions can help people identify
those patterns they may have in
themselves
that are
taking
occasional negative thoughts which
everybody has
and magnifying those into
more persistent negative states
once you if you work at this it's kind
of like homework this is what we call
cognitive behavioral therapy
it's very structured very organized you
work hard it requires insight and
motivation and you have to be motivated
but if you are then you can identify
these triggers that send you down
particular pathways and work to
intercept them and that is
amazingly very effective in mild to
moderate cases so you're basically
have to train yourself to see the world
as a
collection of triggers and you have to
first understand like collect the data
like basically see every experience
as a thing that creates a follow-on
emotion of feeling
and like i've learned this
you know like on social media
where like early on
you know like all of us
um you know i'll i'll say something i
kind of respond to negativity
with negativity
and then you observe
the results of that
over time
you think wait a minute
th this thing that i've been doing where
when somebody says you suck and you say
no you suck
that never produces the result you
thought it might
and so might not want to just
don't say you suck back
and i do this through a lot of things in
life
i'm very fortunate to
not suffer from
depression but
i
first of all i have had and have people
in my life who do
and and also you know all of us
have depression who don't suffer from
depression have depression out
like uh it's always knocking on the door
right yeah and so you you have mild uh
i mean uh
if you're very careless with the
triggers
all around you
then you you're just i think all of us
have the capacity to really suffer
uh from that kind of
uh chemical or psychological or
philosophical existential crisis
but then it raises a question why are we
built this way it seems like it doesn't
make sense right um and here's where
some of this thinking about where we
came from
uh
as the human family is is kind of
interesting
does it make sense that somewhere on
that spectrum
that it's good to detect that there's an
array of
adverse forces out there in the world
right now at this moment
and to withdraw
to
to hunker down
to not fight not strive not try to meet
the challenge
and
outweigh
these
negative forces that are present out
there and that makes a lot of sense
uh
and all
animals that have been studied in one
form or another show this even the worm
that i mentioned earlier
c elegans with 302 neurons
it can effectively give up in
challenging situations we've done this
with zebrafish tiny little transparent
fish
you can give them a challenging
situation and they
will give up but then if you
stimulate a couple very specific brain
regions in particular ways you can
motivate them to overcome the challenge
and if you inhibit those regions they
give up much more easily than they would
otherwise you can do this in mice you
can do this in rats
so this is an ancestral conserved
pattern to detect
that things are
pretty bad out there
and to conserve energy
to hunker down to wait out the storm it
says use unfortunately
many of our maladies have
useful roots in in our uh
that contribute to our survival so both
depression and motivation
have uses
and in the pain sometimes it's nice to
just
shut the hell up and huddle with the
penguins
right uh versus
for some unknown reason venture out on
your own into the mountains like a david
goggins type character
so what's the difference to you
between you see patients between sort of
rigorous
um psychoanalysis i don't know if you
consider where you like talk therapy and
psychoanalysis are they neighbors are
they overlapping their their neighbors
uh psychoanalysis is
it's um
they're relatively it's not nearly done
as much as the talk therapy like the
cognitive behavioral therapy i mentioned
uh
the the psychoanalysis is is a little
more niche now and partly because it's
it's not
data isn't um
in terms of actual treatment of actual
therapeutic effects
data not as supportive as for cognitive
behavioral therapy
but it's still interesting as for
insight people a lot of people still do
it to gain insight into themselves
and in general it's a good uh sort of
conversation starter those methods you
know they're good for
getting things out you know
we don't focus on dreams uh typically
these days in psychiatry but they're
great conversation starters they're
great ways to get things out if people
have
uh and so we like to use those methods
just to get the ball rolling sometimes
get people to open up a little bit but
the actual treatment
that tends not to involve these
psychoanalytic approaches where you
are really probing uh the unconscious
mind and its manifestation through
through dreams
for example as as the as the goal that's
not the goal modern talk therapy we're
really focusing on treatment how to get
people to feel better see i use that as
a conversation opener to the freudian
thing where i try to delve at a bar
of the deep sexual desires in a person's
subconscious and i find that opens up
possibilities very quickly no um all
right
what's i mean this is a silly sounding
question but what's the difference
between cognitive behavioral therapy
and conversation
so
um because i personally as a fan of
conversations is a fan of just i like
listening to podcasts
um versus like audio book i like both
but they're very different and i like
conversation i like um it makes me
personally very anxious so i like to be
the listener
uh like like a third wheel like
overhearing a conversation kind of thing
but
it's a really powerful method for humans
to explore each other's mind just raw
conversation so
do you think
it can be more productive to be very
systematic about it or is conversation
itself the art form of
of helping each other understanding each
other and helping each other
there are forms of talk therapy that are
essentially conversational or they much
more approach pure conversation there's
uh there are there's a befriending
therapy there's interpersonal therapy
these are these are approaches that are
purely talk therapy
but they're
not as structured as cognitive
behavioral therapy cognitive behavioral
therapy has is there are manuals there
are guidelines you can almost go through
it in a very cookbooky way there's
there's homework that you get done so
it's
in its fullest form
it's very different from these more
conversational strategies but what's
interesting is sometimes people compare
them and so you'll see
almost like randomized controlled
studies um
comparing cognitive behavioral therapy
with interpersonal therapy for example
and they both can work and actually in
some studies they look uh comparable
um so there's
to your point
conversation and insights that come from
conversation if done well if done
artfully
can be as powerful this reminds me of
robin williams so i have to ask you
several questions here on that but one
of my favorite movies is goodwill
hunting
i don't know if you've seen it with
robin williams
so
as a psychiatrist yourself can you do a
deep analysis of this other famous
psychiatrist which is the movie
character
played by robin williams at goodwill
hunting
this is just a caricature between a
psychiatrist and patient relationship
or is there some
something to you was that was moving
about his ability to connect to this
obviously struggling young kid
i think you've hit on the key thing
there which is the the depth of the
connection if
if there's a
too powerful connection
that can impair uh therapy because it
could impair
open communication if if someone
if a patient has a
sees the role sees the relationship in a
particular way
like in a friendly way maybe or like a
parental
child
type way
that can cause problems because then
what they choose to share what they
choose to bring up
is selected to be appropriate for that
view of the relationship
and so i and many other talk therapists
actually prefer
not to let things get
um
not let the connection get that deep
you want to have trust you want to have
a therapeutic alliance we sometimes call
it
but it's got to be enough of a blank
slate
that the patient
is not
consciously or unconsciously constrained
in what they
choose to share
and so
great movie
great actors
it's all good no complaints except uh
realistically
the relationship should be a little more
uh arm's length than that
let's pretend this is real life
sometimes can't you leave a little bit
of yourself
in the interaction with the patient i
mean it's another human being yes so
it's a balance and actually you do need
some of it um because let's say this
person is having
challenges interpersonal challenges in
their life
the best way
to notice what those are
and to identify them and to work with
them
is if you can elicit some of those
problems
in
in the office in the therapeutic
interaction
and
this is really powerful as long as
you're
alert to it aware of it
and you don't let it go out of hand
this transference we call it is when
you
transfer
in between
the current therapeutic relationship and
external relationships that the patient
may have had with others
and so if the therapist starts to feel
an inner feeling
like anger
let's say so let's say you have a
patient who is stirring
frustration in you or even an extreme
case is anger
the the best thing for the therapist to
do in that case is to recognize it
and to realize
that's probably being stirred by other
people in the patient's life and that
could be the source of a lot of problems
and so instead of trying to wall it off
and say oh i shouldn't be feeling that i
better
be a better therapist instead and
recognize it and use it
and help the patient that way and so
you've got to be a human being you've
got to be a person who feels
and you've got to be open
but be in control of it and be aware of
it
if if i may i just want to read the
because my favorite scenes probably one
of the greatest scenes
one of the greatest scenes in movie
history because robin williams does a
single take
is that right so this is a very
interesting interaction between them so
um will and i'm sure this is a common
interaction
um
maybe with the therapist and a patient
maybe with the father and son
where
will the young character the young
brilliant mathematician and sean is the
therapist the older
uh therapist where will looks at a
painting that sean
painted and then does a like a deep
critical analysis of the painting that
basically
you know describes
uh
pretending as if he can understand
another human being completely but just
looking at their painting
and then sean gives this whole speech
that contrasts sort of raw intelligence
and the wisdom of experience
and sean says single take
he says you've never been out of boston
right
and will says nope
all this in a sexy boston accent by the
way
uh and then sean gives the speech
if i asked you about art you probably
give me this skinny and about every art
book ever written michelangelo you know
a lot about him life's work political
aspirations him and the pope sexual
orientation the whole works right
but i bet you can't tell me what it
smells like in the sistine chapel
you never actually stood there and
looked up at that beautiful ceiling seen
that
if i asked you about women you'll
probably give me a syllabus
of your personal favorites
you may have
even been laid a few times
the language here is just beautiful
but but you can't tell me what it feels
like to wake up next to a woman and feel
truly happy
you're a tough kid
if i asked you about war you probably
throw shakespeare at me right probably
not but
let's say
once more into the breach dear friends
but you've never been near one you've
never held your best friend's head on
your lap and watch him gasp his last
breath looking to you for help
if i ask you about love
you'd probably quote me a sonnet
but you've never looked at a woman and
be truly vulnerable
known someone who can level you with
their eyes
feeling like god put an angel on earth
just for you
who could rescue you from the depths of
hell and you wouldn't know what it's
like to be
her angel
to have that love for her
be there forever through anything
through cancer
and you wouldn't know about sleeping
sitting up in a hospital room for two
months holding her hand because the
doctors could see in your eyes the terms
visiting hours don't apply to you
you don't know about real loss because
that only occurs
when you love something
more than you love yourself
i doubt you've ever dared to love
anybody that much
i look at you
i don't see an intelligent confident man
i see a cocky scared shitless kid
but you're a genius well no one denies
that
no one can possibly understand the
depths of you but you presumed to know
everything about me because you saw a
painting of mine you ripped my [ __ ]
life apart
you're an orphan right
do you think i know the first thing
about how hard your life has been how
you feel
who you are because i read oliver twist
does that encapsulate you
personally i don't give a [ __ ] about all
that because you know what
i can't learn anything from you that i
can't read in some [ __ ] book
unless you want to talk about you who
you are and i'm fascinated i'm in but
you don't want to do that do you sport
you're terrified of what you might say
your move chief
well done sir i know it's a movie it's
interesting right so some of that
conversation is at some intellectual
level too
it's not just emotional it's something
uh it's like i the reason i kind of
connect with that is
that's a lot of work
for a therapist
like to really understand another
because he's i mean from okay i know
this is fictional but just
there's calculation happening he deeply
cares
to say the words that the other person
needs to hear but also a little bit
loses himself in
the pride
but then catches himself again
switches from anger to uh to connection
yeah
a lot is brought up there that you're
right there there has to be some emotion
in the therapist to care enough to keep
going to to keep probing to open up
as he's doing so right
he revealed a lot about himself his own
vulnerabilities but that gave him
authenticity
he had to open himself up so that the
the kid would see the authenticity and
open himself up in return
so so how do you do that as a as a as a
psychiatrist as a therapist
you have to be careful you know you
don't want to do
too much uh but opening up a little bit
does
help it does create
uh a chance you know you're offering up
something and that helps the patient
come back in return
and it gives it gives you that that
believability and authenticity do you
pay the price for that for opening it up
you can um
you have a family you have an incredibly
like difficult research like you're
doing a lot of things in your world i
mean it's the price you pay for like
well this is one of the terrifying
things about about writing the book was
was
i i do open up uh in a little bit about
my own personal life my own personal
challenges and that was a considered
decision because
uh i could i could have done
the the patient work and the science
work and the
and the history of the human family work
and and tied it all together
but but it wasn't and i i in an early
draft it was it was like that
but it wasn't it wasn't real yet it
wasn't
it wasn't uh something that that
everybody could connect with and i said
then i realized look if i'm going to do
this
i i've gotta i've gotta open up myself
and then and then people can connect
with me and see
what i'm really saying and so i did and
that was
it was not something that um i'd gone in
planning to do
in retrospect i learned a lot about
myself it was actually really i think a
good thing that i i did but
it was scary
where are the darkest places you've ever
gone in your life
you know i had uh
things haven't haven't always been been
easy personally or you know or
professionally i had i had moments you
know i was effectively a single dad for
for a while a number of years and these
came at probably the hardest also
professional
life times for me too
the absolute hardest uh days of late
medical school internship you know
taking call
you know getting up at 3am you know
surgery uh
medicine rounds unforgiving environments
and then all the while you know personal
life uh you know stripped down to the
bear um
and these were low moments and then i
was hit particularly hard by
just experiences on
on the clinical ward connecting too
deeply with patients like you know a
child with a brain tumor and feeling it
too strongly and and those
things uh
when you get down to those lowest of the
low moments when everything is is
stripped away and and there's there's
only this this raw
core well yeah
that's pretty hard those that was
probably the the lowest moment and you
learn a lot about yourself in those
moments you know what's what's left and
and then what are the
the the roots out from there and and
that's
that's that can be powerful to to see
uh in yourself
have you thought about killing yourself
i have not
i have not have you seen that thought in
the distance
i am fortunate that that has not
come to my mind and i have not seen it
in the even in the distance and i in in
in some ways i've i've wondered if
that's made me
am i a less
you know effective psychiatrist because
of that i've been
i've felt everything stripped away i've
been at the lowest of the low
and yet the the that there's still hope
there's a light of hope still at the end
of the day
right
so you never lost even for brief moments
that um
i never did
i don't know
you don't know why there was no reason
you don't know why no reason to feel
hope at that moment honestly
uh
so it was just the light without reason
yeah that's right
what wisdom do you draw from that time
about
so first of all
you said something funny which is i
wonder if it
that it's somehow not having
thoughts of suicide
limits your capacity to truly understand
somebody who is
having those thoughts
so how many demons must the psychiatrist
have
in order to be a good psychiatrist yeah
you know this is a really interesting
question i think everybody knows and i
can say this that psychiatrists
can be a little unusual there we
we think about ourselves right we think
about our brains that may be one reason
why we become psychiatrists is we think
oh that's interesting going on in there
what's that about so a little little
introspective a little introverted maybe
and that's what can make us good
when we're good
and
but also that
that may select for people who have some
unusual aspects but you don't have to
have all of them
there's a lot that can can go wrong in
the in the psychiatric realm uh i think
having
some of those some of it but not all of
it is enough you get to see
how low things can can get
you can get a
you get empathy from that even if the
symptoms are not the same um just
empathy for struggle for suffering
that's right that's right
do you yourself have to practice
observing triggers
just as a human operating in this world
i've definitely those those skills that
have come from
from therapy i've i've found i found
them useful yeah if i noticed that uh
we've all been through experiences where
we wondered oh i got really mad in that
interaction
why did i get that mad you know yeah
sure maybe i could have been irritated
but man why did i yeah and and and then
thinking about it and realizing okay you
know
back up here think about the broader
context
um uh
think about
what how that relates to you know prior
events in my life okay yeah so this is a
thing for me uh when something of this
class happens
then it triggers me
so going forward i'm going to be aware
of that
um
and i've definitely used that because
it's
you don't you don't want to be out of
control those emotions you want to
identify them you want to know where
they come from and
you want to head them off as a as a
civilized human being living on this
earth trying to get along with other
people you want to understand those
moments let me um
return to robin williams for a second
and looking at robin williams the
the actor the uh sorry the human
and because you mentioned um
for depression you can have everything
going well
and i think there's just
uh
famous cases of just public figures
because a lot of people know them
where
they they suffer quietly
and it seems like from the outside
perspective that they
have everything going for them that
they're top of their career
you know two people that come to mind
are
robin williams and anthony bourdain
what insight do you have and why
either of those taken why robin williams
a comedian one of sort of the most jolly
humans obviously there was always the
darkness that he was channeling
channeling in order to
present the happiness but it feels like
that realness is only possible when
you're deeply self-honest and analytical
and
and then then if you're deeply
self-honest you're going to realize that
there's a lot of beautiful things about
life that you can discover and if you do
that how can you possibly then take your
own life and you go through all these
thoughts and
i think a lot of a lot a lot of people
really loved robin williams which is why
it was really difficult to see how can
even
him how can even robin williams take his
own life so
i don't know if there's something to be
said about the nature of depression from
just looking at his case
i think
the action of suicide is not well
understood uh it it doesn't always
although often is correlated with
depression there are cases of suicide
where there is not clear depression that
that's in the minority by the way if i
just look because you said it's so
interesting action of suicide because
there's also thoughts of suicide that's
right and probably those that probably
somewhat understood but it's an
interesting
because you can think of suicide
if you have suicidal ideation you can
think of that for so many reasons
that's right
and
and the
i mean i
thoughts
sometimes like painful thoughts
angry thoughts or thoughts in general
can be very different like fantasies for
example you can fantasize
like sexual fantasies you can um
fantasize i was just for humor's sake
wanted to mention stuff but then people
think i'm serious i'm not going to
mention anything but
sexual fantasies and then there's i know
there's people that have sexual
fantasies and they don't want to
actually do that in real life that that
that sexual fantasy serves some kind of
purpose in imagination only and in that
same way suicide might serve a purpose
and imagination only is very unlikely to
lead to action and yet there's other
thoughts that maybe are more amorphous
that do lead to action and that leap
uh yeah that oh boy that's a facet and
that's such a philosophically powerful
thought to not exist right like that
question uh that's this uh is it sarcher
or kamu
kamu well the mythicist
who says like basic question of why live
question yeah right
so
that's a great question actually and
there are other related questions some
people
may have the thought of suicide
because
there seems no point there's no joy in
life that's one reason that some people
can put forward
sometimes there's an it's not just the
absence of of joy there's an active pain
an active psychic pain in some people
and that the inescapability of that
is enough to drive the thoughts of
suicide
and then there are interpersonal and
cultural reasons as well that can show
up
the but the act this act of ending of
the self is
in all these cases there's no real way
to study this in animals no other animal
as far as we know that we can study
has this concept of this is myself
the situation is not
tolerable therefore i will end the self
to our knowledge this is not something
that that can be studied in other
animals so it remains this this uh
uh very poorly understood action and
in predicting it so what do we do with
psychiatrists we have this challenge
people come to the emergency room
they say they're suicidal or their
friends say they're suicidal or they've
taken some action
that that didn't lead to death what do
we do well there's a whole range of
options you know was it a suicidal
gesture in the sense of not intending
death
or was it
was the intent
death
and if it was the intent was was death
what were the reasons are the reasons
transient are they gone now
what's the probability that it'll be
repeated
so we do all these things just to decide
what sort of treatment should be carried
out but nowhere
is there a deep understanding of the
biology of the cells and circuits
and activity patterns that underlie the
end
the action to end the self
it's a very
it's so it's this
frustrating thing it's it's so
timely it's so common it shows up in
veterans it shows up in kids it shows up
in people at every stage of life
and yet we're very bad at
understanding it and we're relatively
poor at predicting it and our tools are
are not very
powerful we can put people in a locked
unit we can give them care therapy for a
while at some point
we release them and there's only so much
we can do it's one of the most
frustrating things and the suffering
that is linked to suicidality but it is
a decision and it is an action
and if you look at optogenetics you
should be able to
one day sort of understand the dynamics
of such
weighty decisions
the individual causes then if someone is
anhedonic if there is no joy in life
that
very likely is addressable by
optogenetics we know how to
turn that dial very robustly in animals
the
motivation to overcome challenges that
we have some some hope of understanding
psychic pain internal negative states we
have actually a handle on that as well
there's a structure in the brain called
the habenula
and some linked structures around it
that seems to generate this negative
internal state that's it's active when
a state of acute disappointment acute
outcomes that go wrong uh not as
expected
you know
moments of unexpected pain uh the
habenula is there it seems it's active
to report on internal uh negativity with
its with its action
and so you could imagine strategies to
target this brain structure that
might have the effect of reducing
psychic pain reducing the negativity of
internal states that is a very concrete
hope it's precise it's anatomical
optogenetics has given us all the firm
foundation we need
to go
after that question so i think there is
hope uh if you look at the individual
causes the individual symptoms relating
to suicide
and then it's like a puzzle you put
together the puzzle pieces well by the
way i do think my
uh habenula
is uh
very functioning very actively
and i wonder if it's like because
because you you can also learn to
channel these things right some some of
the things we suffer from
i mean there's degrees of suffering can
be
um a source of
progress and personal growth and
development and all those kinds of
things and i mean i
um
what is it nietzsche suffered from
stomach issues
you know
i wonder if you've written some of those
things if
if his stomach was all great
right i mean that there's i kind of
think that
uh a difficult life in some form you can
get you get to choose in some regard and
some of you don't the difficulties you
have and the ones you do have it's nice
to use if possible it's sometimes it's
nice to treat sometimes it's nice to
it's nice to use well the way you phrase
it i think you're using it i could be
wrong
but if you you phrased in this
semi-humorous way about your habenula it
seems to me that you're you're using
that
to good effect now
but one never really knows what someone
else's internal state is as i look at
you i don't know the depths of what's
going on and it's possible uh that that
it's it's it's a much harder situation
in there um yes
so that's i actually worry about this a
lot so i'm extremely self-critical like
in the privacy of my own mind which is
an interesting thing when you get to
meet the internet and the internet will
tell you you suck
uh
but
for for now now this is what i worry
about and i'm very paying attention for
now it's really i just have this like
very negative voice
but that voice seems to be very useful
for productivity yes and so i channel it
i just put on the table and let that
voice like talk to me but i'm very i'm
like
monitoring that voice because looking at
robin williams you know you get older
your brain changes or like your and and
then that voice can now all of a sudden
grow
right and then where you can't control
as much just be very careful with these
kinds of things you're very right about
that i so my my negativity i have this
uh i never think i've done enough is
sort of where my my negativity comes
from inside i i i never think
that i've
i've
met the potential of the moment i
haven't done
uh i haven't you know
made the most of the opportunities that
are available
still early i haven't you know
you know progressed as far as i should
and exactly as you're saying
that works for a while
but then what happens as as you get
later in life and there's less
runway
to
you know fix that and then maybe maybe
then maybe then that negative voice is
is a problem but also at that point the
negative voice starts having more and
more of a point that's when when you're
being when you're being very successful
it's easy to be like no okay well
like later in life you're really
literally just sitting there on a
on a rocking chair doing nothing and
then
it's
or maybe any kind of tragedy happens
loss of a loved one
loss of a job
loss or you get screwed over in some
kind of
um some kind of way i don't know those
and then also in the negative voice is
just you and the negative voice for
days and days and days and so i don't
know
to go back to your example of robin
williams i don't know what was going on
inside him i don't know the nature of
his internal state was it a was it
active psychic pain that
may have mentioned may interrupt to just
say that sergey posted an examination of
robin williams's brain tissue suggested
that he suffered from quote diffuse
l-e-w-y lewy body dementia
lbd depression is a symptom of lbd and
it's not about psychology it's rooted in
urology this is words from
his brain was falling apart yeah louis
body dementia this is a very interesting
neurological disorder where
among other things there are there's
neuron death indeed so you've got frank
neuron loss it's not just a matter of
some long-standing
psychic pain but you've got a
progressive
loss and so clearly you've got a
situation where he could have finally
reached a point where
the balance that he'd worked out between
negativity and positivity uh
was disrupted due to loss the wrong
cells died the wrong projections were
cut by the lewy body dementia certainly
dopamine neurons die in lewy body
dementia those are neurons that give
rise to
much of the feelings of reward and
pleasure that we experience among other
roles
so
uh clearly in his case there could have
been a very
concrete cellular neurological issue
that was progressive and pushed him to
that point
but what were you uh
were you about to make a point about
broader that if there isn't another
neurological degeneration yeah so in his
case not knowing that uh
it could have been simply that let's say
he had
an internal psychic pain state and it
was in
he was in sort of a compensated mode for
much of his life able to generate enough
joy from his his comedy and his social
interactions and
and then but eventually later in life
you know the
the those things drop away the balance
shifts you get tired of fighting the
pain for that long and then so you've
got this time dependent
non-stationarity that happens and then
the same
symptom becomes no longer tolerable in
the end
what is autism what do we know about
autism
human beings exist on a spectrum of uh
how social we can be
and this is pretty interesting actually
scientifically but also
very important uh clinically
there are hypersocial states where
people are
almost too social there are chromosomal
deletion states where people have
instant
affinity and bonding and and rich deep
seeming
connections with people very verbal
on the other end
people with autism spectrum disorder are
not
able to
keep up with social interactions and
it's a it's a spectrum some have
mild to moderate difficulties they
may have inability to understand what
the next thing to do in a social
situation is but may have
perfectly good language abilities
and as you progress further along the
spectrum that gets more and more severe
so they
can't make eye contact because it's too
overwhelming to think about what has to
be done next if a person looks in a
particular way yeah
and then as you go farther then
language
and social communication themselves
break down so there's no
reciprocity there's no shared enjoyment
and that this gets very hard then as you
get to this far end of the spectrum
where there's
really an absence of social cognition at
all uh and and social bonding
so why why does this exist what is it uh
it's very genetic as i mentioned it's
it's one of the you know top three or
four most biological in the sense of
most genetically determined of the
psychiatric illnesses it does have these
interesting positive correlations slight
positive correlations with
intelligence and education
and
the reason for that is kind of
interesting to think about
is there something good about it just
like
or
at least with at least part of the
spectrum is there's something good about
it just as we were talking about for
depression
as you could say for mania as you could
say for schizophrenia
and
here it's kind of interesting to think
about the
the underlying science of what it means
to be good at a social interaction the
someone who's very good at a social
interaction is incredibly good at
dealing with unpredictable
information
is able to handle this torrent of
information coming through
rapidly changing
a model of the other person and of the
interaction and their model of you
your model of them
with each word that changes with each
new bit of information that comes in
through the conversation each bit of
body language all this is rapidly
changing and some people
are
able to keep up with that fire hose
information perfectly well
but that's a special brain state to be
in that's working with
unpredictability that's
you know uh
the only way that can be done is most
likely by constantly
running models of what the other person
might be about to say
so you can't stop and think oh what did
that word mean what did that
shift in eye contact mean
you know what do they mean together
there has to be some advanced work going
on where you're predicting what's going
on if you're to keep up with a rich and
fast social interaction
now
on the flip side
there are
brain states that maybe don't have to
work so fast that are extremely
important still dealing with something
that's not moving
or that's predictable still complex
like
uh you know mathematical proof or a very
complex arrangement of geometrical
shapes uh a large number of individual
non-moving things
there's a
possibly a way of being that's
particularly good at dealing with these
static unmoving or predictable
situations
and less so with these rapidly changing
social situations
and so the way i conceptualize autism
is these are people who whose brains are
not so good with the high bit rate
unpredictable information but may be
quite good at giving enough time
given
the
grace to work with
the system
to look at it from different angles
to take different perspectives with the
confidence that it's not changing
in between perspectives
that's a brain state that's valuable
it's something that has probably
has contributed to a lot of the success
of the human family being able to design
something being able to consider
the
the
all the different contributions to a
static predictable
system
so autism in a sense is a
is a spectrum that has
identifiable characteristics about the
way people deal with dynamic information
often expressed itself as like social
that's right dynamic information but you
critically your use of the word often
there is really i think smart because
it's not just social interaction that is
a challenge in autism and so many people
conceptualize it purely as a social
dysfunction
disorder
but it's really any unpredictable
information that's a problem that's a
challenge for for people on the spectrum
they react very
negatively to unexpected sounds even if
not social sounds unexpected lights
unexpected touches
and so it's really unpredictable
information that is uh in my view the
core problem with with the processing
and autism not just social social just
shows up because it's so unpredictable
yeah it's so interesting i mean um
i tried to not to think about that stuff
um
i'm afraid of thinking disor about
disorders and things like that because
just like i don't like sort of economics
or game theory
uh i won't be careful with it because
it uh whenever you have a category or a
model it's too easy to just uh for every
i mean it's the ocd thing i like models
too much i like categories too much the
moment you acknowledged yourself well i
have an eating disorder for example or
something like that as opposed to just
being a well i'll just i'll just leave
it at that for my own critical
understanding of myself uh let's just
say i don't know how to moderate eating
fruit people make fun of me they think
all fruit just fruit is healthy
i know
[Laughter]
i don't well i don't know how to
moderate anything but even even fruit uh
this apples and cherries is a nightmare
anyway
that's such a psychiatrist thing to say
very interesting um
but uh but there's characteristics and
and i it's
it's interesting to think about like for
example i have trouble making eye
contact
but i actually as you said it now
it's not that i'm
shy at all in that sense
it's
literally i'm getting way too much
information it's distracting me like i
need to just close my eyes so i can
like all the things that people seem to
be able to do in parallel it's just
you just ask me a question
for me to think about the answer to that
question i can't have all this cool rich
visual information coming my way that's
literally because i often close my eyes
to think it's not because
i'm afraid of something whatever it's
just like too much information happening
here yeah well that's a beautiful
description it's it's amazing that that
is how you experience
the the eye contact uh aspect
i think that's
i mean you've articulated what uh
you know
captures it for for so many people which
is that it's overwhelming there's just
just too much information just coming in
through the eyes
and
to keep up with it to know
you're going to be expected to keep up
with it first of all so there's that
that aspect you know you learned
socially that there's going to be an
expectation if you're making eye contact
people are going to think you're keeping
up with it and
you don't want to because you want to
focus on other things and make progress
in other
you know dimensions
yeah and so that then there's a strong
desire to look away or to close the eyes
because
it's it's it's it's overwhelming it's a
distraction and it's going to cause
errors of of understanding and of course
our eyes that's part the way we use our
eyes as part of the human communications
you have to kind of be aware of that
of that um
that element of it so yeah i mean but
it's fascinating you should be aware of
your own self in those those little
characteristics
whether it's uh
whether it's classified on some aspect
of the uh autism spectrum or just in
general whether it's eating whether it's
depression
whether it's um even like schizophrenia
that would i hope we get a chance to
talk to a a little bit yeah but those
things are all made up of different care
symptoms and characteristics
and use use them as a superpower i i
suppose this is the best we can hope for
in mild cases i guess i do think both
brain states can't coexist at the same
time the way of dealing with something
unpredictable and dealing with something
predictable
there those are different ways of being
here's a huge opportunity for
very creative
model building in theoretical
neuroscience
and linking that to these data streams
we're getting across the brain
that we talked about earlier these
immense data sets of activity across the
brain
here's where i think there could be a
real convergence of theoreticians and
experimentalists to say okay
given what we know about wiring of the
brain
here is what
the brain state is likely to be that
deals well with unpredictable
information and here's the brain state
that deals with predictable information
here's why they're incompatible at least
at the same time here's why you've got
to be able to detect
which state you should be in here's how
you could switch between them here's the
kind of cells that you would predict
almost like predicting the higgs boson
here's the kind of circuitry that i
would predict should govern the
switching
or
might make one
state too sticky too hard to get out of
right yeah that is a huge opportunity
for an interaction from the theoretical
and experimental side together
make one state too sticky
the
sort of uh measure the stickiness of the
state and how to lessen the stickiness
that's right get some oil in the machine
yes yeah what would predict the kind of
oil that would work well
uh what in your practice is um
treatment or advice
for the people on the autism spectrum so
right now there's no real medical
treatment there are behavioral
treatments
that are most effective early in life
they make sure people don't fall too far
behind
if you're not interacting socially you
create this
you know vicious cycle where you fall
farther and farther behind because
you're not interacting and these these
therapies which are applied early in
life
therapists work with the kids
train them to deal with these things
that otherwise would be aversive to them
teach them how to predict things and
interact and that
has a big effect but it's behavioral
therapy there's no medicine that works
there are ways of reducing individual
symptoms though that sometimes come
along with autism and those do respond
to medications so you can you know one
thing very often my patients with autism
are very anxious
because
they live in a world that they have a
really hard time predicting what's going
to happen and so they find
and some of these are high functioning
you know silicon valley types who you
know they might make you know
great livings but they're very unhappy
because they're on the spectrum
they
don't
understand how social interactions
really work they're very
uh anxiety provoking because they don't
know what to say they don't have any
clue how anybody else knows what to say
they're constantly worried they're going
to say something that's completely
inappropriate and so they're very
anxious and i can i can treat their
anxiety it doesn't touch the autism per
se but i can help them with their
anxiety
what i just talked about eye contact
i
am richly even with eyes closed and all
those kinds of things i'm richly
experiencing the world and it's not like
you're afraid of the world or you're not
able i don't know what to do no i know
everything in fact i know way too much
there's so many cool options like at any
one moment
there's all the stuff happening and it's
all beautiful and at any one moment you
can do anything you want you can take
off your clothes you can punch that guy
over there you can uh
run away you can go in for a hug you can
say something profound and deep or you
can say something generic or you could
use so many things you can say
and then and then it'll go it'll unravel
in all these kinds of ways and this
moment could be completely life-changing
or it can be mundane and meaningless and
all of those options are before you at
any one moment
and so that's amazing
it's amazing and overwhelming if you
allow yourself to think about it yes
which uh what whatever exactly like well
unfortunately with chess you have a few
set options two-dimensional dimensions
constraints
there is unlimited possibilities and
unlimited beautiful things happening all
around you so i don't think there's a
kind of sense that somehow you're
limited
in your
in in the places
of uh
in the way you can see the world and how
you can interact with that world i am
overwhelmed by
the lack of limit
that all of us should be have you looked
around you could do whatever the hell
you want nobody will remember you anyway
mo all of us will be dead one day you
could do anything
you can uh
i don't know you can get naked and run
around the city as long as you're not
hurting anybody and it doesn't matter
so it's austin anyway
exactly seems like uh a to-do item for
anybody living in austin for sure
but you know the the spectrum is an
interesting concept because
that is you know when i say when i refer
to the spectrum
uh i'm actually referring to it's a
precise clinical term but you're right
it's been co-opted more broadly and it
is widely used and it can be
an unfair categorization of someone
who's
socially and occupationally very healthy
and that
is critical
because we we don't define a disorder
unless there's social or occupational
dysfunction it doesn't matter what the
symptoms are i've had
patients who are pleasantly
hallucinating so frankly psychotic but
doesn't affect their lives so i don't
give that person
as diagnosis because there's not social
or occupational dysfunction
same with
any anything on this
you know any of the diverse symptoms of
autism spectrum disorder
if someone has them
but they're
successful socially and occupationally
we don't say that there's a disorder
but then you're right the concept of the
spectrum does become a useful uh you
know pigeonholing um device which is
maybe not not the best thing
yeah and eye contact is interesting one
is interesting one i'm torn on it
talking about the usefulness of eye
contact because people kind of make fun
of it but
let me just say one thing about eye
contact and about life in general it's
okay to be weird
but like some people when you have your
eyes closed and there's that weird what
is happening to this creature like you
see a weird creature on the side of the
road it's interesting yeah and you want
to i mean the the weird stuff i'm going
to go back to robin williams with the
that's the good stuff
right he has that whole speech about him
and his wife and what he loves all the
little peculiarities all the weird stuff
and that like um
let those flourish yes uh let the like
celebrate those in yourself and not in
some kind of woke way but in some like
very human way this is what makes us
this is the weirdness yeah
i i'm 100
on board with that i and i don't think
you know
people who are
happy and who have
people in their lives
who are happy with them these are
i think let let the weirdness flourish
let the let the
all the different ways members of the
human family can be different let's see
them all that's one of our
that's one of the joys of being alive is
seeing all the ways we can be human
and i i think about it all the time
why
do we have all these ways of being human
uh
and
even within one individual you go
through phases of life where you express
different
sides of your way of being which is also
a pretty fun opportunity right you can
go through
phases where you're in one mode and
phases in another mode
and let that you know just
let that let that flourish too let the
ways that you can be you uh vary as well
i think that's important for people to
explore and i should
like because if you can address the uh
the
uh the internet but i i would like to
sort of ask the internet
to celebrate
the uh the the weirdness of people like
that's
uh that's the robin williams uh
uh people call these imperfections but
they're not that's the good stuff for
any one individual person
find the weird stuff and celebrate it
as opposed to
what the internet often does which is
find the weird stuff
and criticize it
because when you criticize the weird
stuff you're creating conformity which
is another human thing
but that that conformity creates a a
boring
world you want the weird
you want the crazy that's what fun is
made of that that that's the uh the
foundation of humor and
the all the ways in which we deal with
the with the with the suffering in the
world with the injustices in the world
is
like this like huge variety of weird
okay
uh
yeah i don't know
and that's what at the depth of
psychiatry is like you want to
uh acknowledge the weird celebrate the
weird like step around it to find
the particular aspects of weird that are
debilitating like you said they're
somehow negatively affecting your
ability to function in the world as
opposed to trying to
shut it all down that's right
well on that topic i mean i'd love to
talk to you about schizophrenia
what what is schizophrenia
from your research and from your general
understanding and what is the full
landscape of suffering
and uh
wisdom that schizophrenia explores
schizophrenia is a state where
there is a break from reality and so
this can show up as we call
them the positive symptoms of
schizophrenia
these include hallucinations
hearing something or seeing something
that's not there usually auditory
hallucinations
paranoia people can have complex
fears delusions which we call fixed
false beliefs people get an extremely
unshakeable but completely implausible
idea about something sometimes it
relates to themselves sometimes to the
world
these we call the positive symptoms
break from reality as we know it
then there are the negative symptoms
that come with it and these are
progressive these are
flattening of of emotion as we call it
so starting to express less and less
positive emotion ending more in a
neutral or flat state
thought disorder inability to
work with complex patterns of planning
or thinking so you can't make plans
you'd have poor working memory you can't
keep track of where you were
in a conversation
in a sequence of actions
so
poor
and impaired working with the thoughts
of oneself and then these
these positive symptoms of break from
reality okay now why does why does this
why do these come together
what's the neurobiology of it again we
don't know schizophrenia extremely
genetically determined if you look at
the numbers could be upwards of 80
percent genetically determined
um
one percent of the human population
around the world it's it's universal
okay it's not confined to any one
culture not even really biased in one
you know
culture another about one percent around
the world
and
has this progressive quality to it
untreated so it's very interesting
there's a break that happens we call it
first break
when
someone experiences their first
disruption of reality they can have a
completely typical life up into that
point so you might have a and i've seen
you know just heartbreaking cases of
like this like this in the
stanford emergency room where a kid
who's come there has been
extremely
you know high functioning in that sense
of academic achievement and athletic and
interpersonal and then comes to college
usually in men it's it's around 18 19
when the first break happens
some terrifying
paranoia hits or some
auditory hallucinations start they're
getting screamed at by a voice in their
head so devastating
with women
comes on also often a little later
sometimes in the 20s
and it can be progressive if it's not
treated
it just progresses and progresses the
the voices become
overwhelming the delusions and paranoia
extend and expand the thought the
negative symptoms particularly become
more and more severe
so one can't even
maintain thoughts in any sort of ordered
fashion
and then eventually uh you know it can
be fatal can lead to suicide it can lead
to erratic behavior that leads to
accidents
now
it can be treated there are medications
that help uh
fortunately they have side effects so
they're not perfect you can have
movement problems and
uh
actually a whole host of different side
effects that come from the medications
but we can help people now with with
schizophrenia very very significantly
but the amazing thing and this is
emblematic of where psychiatry stands
we don't have the deep understanding
just like with depression we don't have
that heart as a pump
level of understanding
that we'd like to have with
schizophrenia despite it being so
biological so genetic in its nature
so is there a way
once
a wait to return to the other side of
the first break
so when you have a break with reality
it's a way to kind of
stitch it together yeah so some people
that that works
but we don't really know how so
medications antipsychotic medications we
call them they block a particular
neurotransmitter receptor called the
serotonin
2a receptor
and they modulate dopamine as well and
other neurotransmitters
these can take someone who's actively
hallucinating actively paranoid put them
back in a completely normal state and
some people
stay that way
indefinitely and so you can bring people
back from from that back to the other
side have it stitched together
more typically um
you'll end up in some intermediate state
where
there's a symptoms are reduced
powerfully but there might be still
something there and you've got a drop
down in
functioning that may be persistent for a
while
but
concepts what physically is going on one
idea is that
it's communication
within the brain one part of the brain
is not able to tell other parts of the
brain what it's doing and so the
auditory hallucinations are very
interesting in this regard
they often have this conversational
inner monologue like quality as we're
walking along the street we may have an
inner monologue thoughts about what's
going on
if we see somebody we don't like we
might have a thought out where somebody
would punch that guy something like that
or maybe i should punch that guy but we
these are so far below
where we would ever you know act or even
think of acting but they're just things
that come up and and people with
schizophrenia
those inner thoughts that inner
monologue is not recognized as the inner
monologue of the self and so it's it's
perceived as something coming from
the outside
uh or from inside but from a another
entity another
another room yeah inside the same
building another room on the inside
there yeah yeah
and so that that's so it's a it's a it
could be conceptualized as a
communication within the brain problem
notifying what's another part of the
brain what's going on and there's some
evidence uh consistent with that
i don't know if you can help with this
but i sometimes
have been talking to quite a few
homeless folks recently just
that's what i do is i
hang out at night
um
and
uh talk to interesting people
and some of them and i've known people
in the past who suffer from
schizophrenia and some of them like self
will describe
uh as as a as that as something they
suffer from
and they seem to understand something
deeply about this world
i don't know if it's correlated
or
or maybe it's it's another aspect of
like depression all those things that
i've encountered
in my own life
is maybe just the struggle and the
suffering
has taken you through a life where you
think deeply about life like there's
like self-reflection
that society forces on you
because it's a disorder somehow or some
kind
is it interesting i i guess my only sort
of anecdotal observation is people who
suffer from schizophrenia
seem to be very interesting and
very thoughtful in a non-linear way
about the world
i've noticed that it's not always
positive uh they're the unusual ways
they view the world it was
but it's always interesting it's uh it
could be conspiratorial thinking too
yeah like but like the the theories they
have about the way the world functions
it often very well read which is also
interesting
because they're almost like looking for
helpful answers from somewhere
absolutely and so they're you know they
might be citing some very interesting
literature and then using that
um
there's a stickiness in their mind to
different models of the world and trying
to make sense of that world and those
models could include conspiracy theories
yeah
they're very attuned to complexity and
they come up with unlikely
explanations uh which is one of the
things that makes them it makes it hard
for them to function in the in the world
is how unlikely their explanations are
but but you're right there's a depth of
consideration of the complexity of the
world
and a concern about it and a work uh a
an impulse to work to understand it that
is actually quite refreshing um
but
you know the first case in the medical
literature
uh there was a
classical schizophrenia
there was a patient named james tilly
matthews who
had this uh he sketched out for his
doctor the
uh experiences he was he was
sensing and he drew himself as a
a cowering figure on the ground
controlled
by a loom a weaving device that was
sending threads
long threads projections across space
from the loom to him to his arms and to
his body and controlling him
from afar
and he called this the heirloom
a loom in the air
and
it was such an evocative thing because
you know this was the start of the
industrial revolution or mid and it was
where you know
really industrial strength
you know looms and weaving devices were
really uh kind of the
emblematic of the most
complex
powerful technological achievements of
the time and so that was the explanation
available to him to explain how
his body was seemingly moved without his
volition uh
and these days of course people with
schizophrenia will have more
technology appropriate interpretations
they'll
have a
you know delusions of satellite or alien
control or
beamed information very very common to
have this delusion of
a government agency
you know sending electromagnetic or or
radio frequency information to control
their limbs
but it's this it's the same thing it's
that whether it's a thread from an
industrial revolution loom
or
you know rf you know radiation it's the
same thing just adapted to the to the
moment explaining trying to explain the
world they live in in their relationship
to the world but unconstrained by sort
of
the thing that's socially acceptable
which is that's right both refreshing
and dangerous yes
i wrote down a question
why do we cry
our tears a window into some depths that
we ourselves don't know
i almost want to make fun of myself for
that question but you do talk seriously
about crying in the book in fact the
whole first chapter really really
tussles with crying as a as why do we do
it what does it mean why is it
involuntary it seems like a weakness
right it's because it's so involuntary
and it's reflecting something true and
inside
at the level of the individual that
seems like a problem right wouldn't it
be better if we could control it if if
we could
not show that emotion
when it's not useful show it when it's
useful but it's not it's it's largely
involuntary
and so
there's a value to it i think as an
honest reporter of a need of hope
and frailty at the same time i i'm a
human being
there's a
frail
a frailty to myself or my situation
where i need social help i need help
from my community
i have hope that that is possible
uh but
i'm not enough for myself i need the
community that that i think is what the
the social signal of crying is now
people have studied crying
uh it's an extreme you can you can
quantify
the extent to which the presence of
tears on a face
triggers
reactions in onlookers and
and you can show the same face in the
presence or absence of tears and show
that to to people under quantifiable and
rigorous uh you know
psychological conditions
and
tears are much more powerful at stirring
the desire to help
in
viewers than any other
facial uh feature
which is pretty interesting that it's
the it's the honest one that's also the
most powerful right it kind of indicates
there's a certain logic to our design
at as social beings that we have an
honest
report
that's hard to uh hard to control and
but is it is it well understood
what how that connects to
the internal state
of emotion yeah
there are
long-range projections that come so
where where is crying generate this is
the confusing thing about it so that we
have a little tear duct the lacrimal
gland that leads to the release of fluid
it ejects fluid and it comes out and
those of course
that whole system was designed to keep
the eye clean to wash out particulate
irritants so it's it's a long standing
as long as we've had eyes and have been
out of the water
uh in our evolution we've needed this
sort of thing so long-standing
biological structure recently co-opted
it seems by our evolution as social uh
primates
now how could that happen well the
lacrimal gland is controlled by
structures in the ponds which is a
structure deep in our
just above our neck between our neck and
our head
and reflecting its ancient origin right
as you go farther down toward the spinal
cord these are the more basic early
evolved structures and and in the ponds
that's where breathing is controlled
tear
duct uh contraction
and
what we found and with optogenetics we
helped sort this out there are long
range projections from fear and anxiety
regions in the forebrain
that project all the way to the ponds in
and around those areas the reason those
are there
we think is to regulate the respiratory
rate changes the breathing changes of
fear and anxiety so we know when we're
in a state of fear and anxiety we need
we cope better if we have elevated heart
rate elevated respiratory rate more
blood pumping around more oxygenated
blood we're ready to meet the threat if
it happens
all those cells are down there in the
ponds too right next to
the lacrimal gl duct the tear gland
neurons and so almost certainly this
fear anxiety anxiety-induced
crying arose from a very slightly
misdirected long-range projection that
was there
to regulate
breathing and a little twist just a
little misdirection a little missing
of one sign post to stop here and going
on a little farther
getting to the lacrimal gland neurons
gave us crying
and that's and we just have it that
peculiar sort of structure neuronal
structure that resulted in that that's
that's that's what we're stuck with and
then and ends up being in terms of
social interaction one of the more
important
uh authentic
involuntary displays of interstate
that's right and social communication
oh
yeah is there other stuff like that i
mean do you
yeah i mean the human face is
fascinating as a display of emotion as a
display of
truth and lying and all those kinds of
things i personally
i mean we're all
i suppose
have different
uh sensors that are sensitive to certain
aspects of the human face but to me it
seems like uh the eyes are really
important communication or something
you know i've talked to a few sort of
girls about like botox and stuff like
that it always bothers me when i guess
guys could do this too but like
when women
speak negatively of i guess you can call
them wrinkles
at the uh at the tips of of an eye but
like to me when you smile
when you
wait not wink but like narrow the eyes
to community something is communicating
and those that stuff is really useful
the human face and when it's gone that
something is missing and a lot of little
stuff it feels like can really it's
almost involuntary i guess but it's
harder to describe as the presence or
absence of tears it's like something
about this person you can tell they're
not bullshitting you yeah yeah
and so that was that was what made
presumably that that
tier recruitment so powerful is it just
landed in this very
high value real estate for social
communication if it had gone to you know
there's a lot of
neurons in the in the ponds that control
you know movement of
large you know muscles uh you know
elsewhere that would have been much less
effective as a social signal than
something around the eye so it was
however that that little misdirection
happened it it landed in a great area
for social communication
and because it was coming from the fear
and anxiety
circuits that regulate that necessary
involuntary change in
heart rate and respiratory rate it also
was involuntary and that became valuable
as a as a truth signal as social beings
so
very interesting when you think about
the origins of the human family the
origins of social
structures and our ability and need to
call for help when there's hope
but but need at the same time
what is consciousness
bro so you're actually using techniques
i mean even putting psychiatry aside
just looking
at optogenetics
you're trying to understand some of
these deep aspects of the human mind
and maybe this is a good time to return
to a question you mentioned
you might have an opinion on if there's
such a thing as a theory of everything
for the human mind
because surely answering of what is
consciousness is as
well that's not sure
but it seems like it's a fundamental
part of the human
experience in the human mind and solving
that question
will result in solving
the bigger thing about the human mind
the flip side could be consciousness
it's just the few neurons that are
generating some useful thing that make
us it's like uh
the the sense of self that you talked
about in the uh in the mice maybe it's a
subset of those cells that are just
creating a richer sense of self and
that's it
so
this is a great question
all neuroscientists think about this and
a lot of non-neuroscientists too it's
it's such a
it's the reason a lot of people came to
the study of the brain is to think about
consciousness and not just
being awake or alert but really
what's sometimes called the hard problem
of consciousness which is
what is that nature of that inner
subjective sense we have not just
information processing
but feeling something about the
information that what is that inner
state of subjectivity physically what is
it
and that's called the hard problem of
consciousness and
it's not an extremely well-defined
question everybody has sort of a sense
of what it means
but
it's such a hard problem because you run
into paradoxes quite quickly the more
you think about it and that
is exciting also because it makes us
think actually there's some
there's a big thing that we're missing
the brain is not just a collection of
little tricks there is a big
big concept so that's your sense of
because like a flip side could be with
optogenetics you can
there's an engineering question can you
turn consciousness on and off like a
light switch okay so here here's where
exactly consciousness frames the problem
extremely well and it frames it the
following way so i told you earlier that
we can stimulate 20 or 25 cells in
the visual cortex of a mouse and we can
make it
behave and we can make its brain act as
if it's seeing something that isn't
there we have that level of control now
we can pick out 25 neurons play an
activity
in both behavior and in the brain it's
as if it's seeing something specific
okay
now let's do a thought experiment you
know a good duncan experiment and let's
play this out
let's say we could do the same thing for
every single neuron in the brain of a
human being let's say we had total
control
and i could do something like i could
show you
a rich deep color red and you could look
at it and you would be aware that it's
red but also you might have some
feelings about it some something would
be stirred in you some subjective sense
as you looked at that rich color red
and then
i would take away
the visual stimulus and i would in this
thought experiment i would
using some hyperoptogenetics i would
play in
exactly the same pattern of activity in
every cell in your brain
for as long as it was needed whatever 15
seconds something like that
that exactly matched
what was going on when you were feeling
that inner subjective sense
okay so in that thought experiment a
question for you is would you
be feeling that same inner subjective
sense stimulus is gone every neuron's
doing the same thing because i'm
controlling it
there's a philosophical question there
i'm if if you ask me specifically i
would say yes
okay good most people would say that
because it's hard to say no right it's
very hard to say if every cell in your
brain is doing what it was doing
what what else could be different how
could most normal people would say yes
of course philosophers would then
start saying no they're they're the ones
that say
um i'm i'm going to sort of to parallel
and sorry if it's a bit of an
interruption but if there's you know if
there's a robot that's conscious in
front of you
if it appears conscious
then
it's conscious like to me
uh of course philosophers again speak up
and say well no how do you know it's
conscious well
how do you know anything is conscious
and sort of as normal humans
we tend to uh
lean on the experience versus some kind
of
philosophical concept
so the great thing about the the what
you just said the the turing test is
it's very practical if it acts conscious
it is conscious
but i think that's limiting i like the
the thought experiment i think it's
actually more informative and so i'm
halfway halfway to the to the conclusion
there but let's let's let's take it as
your answer was yes that's that you
would be feeling the same thing okay
now here's where it gets fun
now that every cell in your brain
is knows what it has to do in the sense
that we know it and we're providing it
your brain cells don't need to be in
your head anymore at all right
the only reason they're next to each
other the only reason they're wired
together is to affect each other to
stimulate or inhibit each other
but we don't need that anymore because
optogenetically we're providing that
activity pattern for as long as needed
we're providing the effect of the
communication they don't need to be
connected anymore
they don't even need to be in your head
i could spread your neurons
all over the continent all over the
galaxy
and i could still provide
the same stimulus pattern over 10 or 15
seconds to all those neurons and
somewhere lex friedman would be
would have to be even though no longer
existing as a
physical object anymore would be feeling
that subjective feeling
and it's inescapable because it's
exactly the same as the previous
situation all the neurons have to be uh
spatially
like the locality constraint they have
to be spatially close to each other
uh
and you talk about light opto which is
funny because you know light
is the fastest traveling thing that we
know of
well maybe let's not put them all over
the universe because we might get
relativistic problems then let's let's
just keep them on let's keep all your
neurons let's spread them over north
america okay and let's let's play them
out
same pattern of activity
and right it seems absurd right there's
no way that could be true there's no way
that that that lex would be feeling that
internal sense if his neurons were
spread all over north america
and yet it's exactly the same as the
previous situation where you said sure
wow so we've got a paradox and it and
this is what makes people say paradox
though sorry
yeah yeah maybe products is the wrong
word we got a problem
we got a problem because it reveals
that
there's something big
about
those that internal subjective state
that we we're not explaining and we
don't really have a hope of explaining
in the near future but don't you think
we would still have that
it's just the word internal loses
meaning but don't you think we still
have that internal subjective state
where's
uh
if not then where the heck is the magic
coming from
okay well i just think
i think they're one one of the problems
that i think we need to let go of
is we tend to
outside of the experience of
consciousness the heart problem of
consciousness
we tend to think that we individual
humans are really special
not the subjective experience but the
entirety of it like the body
that contains the things so the local
the the constraint of all the stuff has
to be together and it's all mine
that's a very
i don't know if that has anything to do
with the mechanisms that are creating
this
so i and in fact one really nice way
to break through that is to
either achieve either observe or create
consciousness that spans
multiple organisms
sort of so like that say it's not
it's not an organism-dependent
uh phenomena that the phenomena can
that's just a peculiar way it has
evolved
on earth
but it's it's a it's a phenomena that
doesn't have anything to do with a
specific
biological system
all right so and we have different parts
of
our brain exist and sometimes
create
complex awarenesses
of things that involve
different
neurons that are distributed widely and
that need to communicate with each other
to form this joint representation the
state of consciousness
but indeed why do they have to be in the
same
head we don't
know why that would be the case that
they do
and so that's a
huge
unanswered question in the field is is
what is it
that binds
the activity of neurons together so they
can form a joint representation and
actually this comes back to the
dissociation experiment we talked about
before where you can your sense of self
becomes separated from your your
your body
those things that were refused in a
joint representation the same concept
unitary
are now separate
and
in late 2020 we published a paper in
nature showing how this could be
we used optogenetics to
drive this rhythm that ketamine and pcp
cause in retrospinal cortex and we got
different parts
of the brain to be out of sync and when
they were active
never able to be active at the same time
never able to form
a joint representation at the same time
and so we've got a toehold into these
questions we don't have the answers but
and that mimics the dynamics of ketamine
effects exactly exactly and you're able
to find that kind of oscillation that
wow wow wow let's see if you get even
greater and greater control
with more control over individual
neurons and understanding
like if you think of certain neurons
that having some
role to play in in the sense of self you
can play like an orchestra
um that to create this certain degrees
of consciousness decreases subjectivity
and thereby
understand what is consciousness
but
by having a very complicated light
switch essentially
that and here's the here's the challenge
is
the nice thing about the the thought
experiment is it it kind of highlights
that we're going to hit a point where
we're
addressing some very very fundamental
questions what what
what allows the activity of
two sets of neurons
to become mutually relevant to each
other
this is this is in some ways
maybe the
one of the deepest remaining questions
in neuroscience is is what allows
activity patterns to become
relevant to each other
do they have to be in sync temporarily
do they need to be
is there some other
quality that we don't know about that
also needs to be present to allow cells
to to fuse together into a joint
representation
just just so i understand because it uh
it feels
close to some very very deep idea
so there's a bunch of semi-distributed
signals going on in the brain
and
you're saying there could be
something like a theory of everything if
one to exist is to understand why how
and why signals close to each other
start becoming
relevant to each other that's right
that's right as part of some very much
bigger signal that they're producing
that's right how they coordinate
essentially
um
because it's very distributed i mean
that's a kind of
within a distributed system how is order
achieved
and this is a very specific kind of
distributive system that is one of the
most intelligent that we're aware of
in the known universe
and that would maybe be something also
an understanding of the the full
conscious experience too
that this kind of coordination how does
the coordination between different
neurons that are responsible for sense
of self
how do they begin to form a big picture
that we see as a human experience
that's really really interesting so
uniting the small and i mean
that's actually literally theory of
everything
uniting the small the sort of the theory
of the neuron
um the functioning of the neuron with
the big
just the um
the functioning of the entire mind
that's right and i think keeping a toe
hold in both at the cellular level of
resolution
and the brain wide resolution will be
critical if you lose touch with either i
think you'll miss the big
insight so that's what we're trying to
do
keeping our
keeping grounded in the cellular
resolution trying to keep the the
broadest brain wide perspective
and meet in the middle
do you think you'll see it in your
lifetime a major breakthrough in that
dimension i have hope i have hope i'm
i'm uh it's very hard to predict what
will happen with with big things like
this
if we don't get there there'll be plenty
of other exciting stuff so it's okay
but the other aspect of this whole thing
is that your life is pretty short
that's true so first of all you can die
any day
i tend to try to think about that that
it ends and get in at any moment because
it really really can and if not it'll be
soon anyway do you think about that do
you think about your mortality
i do yeah it's it comes back to what we
talked about earlier i
you know i never think i've done enough
and it's it's relevant to that for sure
there's a deadline yeah
do you think there's ever going to be a
feeling where you sit back and you're
really proud of yourself
i hope so
like i've done enough i've done
everything there is like like you know
because the thing is
a warrior has some number of battles in
them
and at a certain point if you're deeply
honest it's like well this that was a
pretty good run
as far as runs goes that was pretty good
you can hang up your helmet
and then
go sort of drink some ale
listen to some music
with the old lady yeah i'd say i did
pretty good you think you'll get there
i i you know with something
with nature always has surprises for us
we're always the curious mind is always
after more
but yeah true but biology gives us other
rewards you know
children and
family community um and and one can feel
good about those things
biology is full of rewards but do you
think
uh about those rewards what do you think
is the why of those rewards what's the
meaning of life and this existence
what's uh
what's the why of biology
what does it want from us why are all
these cells very busy
putting together an organism that seems
to want to
just be in a hurry to do stuff and
survive but it also just doesn't it's
not happening being survived like you
said it's curious
it keeps wanting to get into more
trouble
why
yeah that you know
that we're clearly designed for that
right this is we're clearly designed to
to ask why and to answer and and that i
think is
i don't i don't know the meaning of all
life
i think a meaning of our lives is that
and you know this is the the
aristotelian you know happiness this is
an organism is happy an animal's happy
if it's performing to its design right
if it's it's
he's doing what it was made for
yeah well you have to understand what
what's what's the design
and
uh
you know
who's the designer and
what were they up to
and
how hard is it do you have to build the
whole universe and does the design even
know what the hell they're doing because
uh
you know maybe the designer built
humorous to find out
about themselves
that's what i would do like if i had the
power to build clones
i'll build a lot of clones and i'll get
them into different trouble
to understand
like what am i design what's this body
designed to do how far can i go that way
exactly
and then and i dissociate myself
completely from having anybody to know
like that i know that person that's good
i mean i suppose you could do that in a
single person's body but dissociation
you can you could yeah
well but i do wonder what
if you if you look at earth
as a collection of humans as the
collection of biological organisms it
seems that we're busy doing something
and
it just seems too beautiful and too
special to be a random
a random experiment
it seems like it's an experiment that's
cleverly designed
that's right
by by some forces of nature that are
beyond our current understanding and
maybe that's part of our design is to
keep asking why he said answer i'm not
sure that's part of the design
the answer
no i think we're given just the
sufficiently limited cognitive
capability that
we know how to long to to find the
answer and we lack the ability to find
the answer
that's basically a summary of your
career no i'm just kidding um and then
we give each other nobel prizes for for
having even an inkling of a
good step towards the right direction
carl you're an incredible human being um
i'm a huge fan of who you are as a
person who you are as a scientist who
you are as a writer i
just thank you so much i'm so honored
that you would sit down and talk to me
today it was amazing it's been
incredibly fun uh let's do it again
sometime it's been really great your
your insights and wit and and
modesty are really uh
quite rewarding thank you so much
thanks for listening to this
conversation with carl diceroth to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
carl young
knowing your own darkness is the best
method for dealing with the darkness of
other people
thank you for listening and hope to see
you
next time
you